WELL GOOD AFTERNOON- WELCOME TO
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY THE HEARING TODAY IS
FOCUSED ON THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS- THIS IS SUB
COMMITTEES THIS IS
SUBCOMMITTEES FIRST HEARING IN
THE ERA OF PHYSICAL DISTANCING
USING TECHNOLOGY TO TAKE.
TESTIMONY FROM PANELISTS
REMOTELY AND PUBLIC COMMENTS
VIA TELEPHONE AGAIN WANT TO
THANK THE SPEAKERS STAFF
ASSEMBLY RULES ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS AND THE LEGISLATIVE
DATA CENTER FOR THEIR HARD WORK
AND ASSISTANCE IN MAKING THIS
HEARING POSSIBLE. I HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO READ DIRECTIONS OF
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARINGS TO HELP
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY WHILE A LOT FULL
PUBLIC ACCESS ALL OF OUR PAST
THIS WILL ARE APPEARING
REMOTELY TODAY FROM REMOTE
WITNESS ROOMS WITH STAFF
MODERATING THE COMP XIN WITH
THE MEMBERS HERE IN THE ROOM-
WE ARE HAVING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANT IN PERSON HEARING WE
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW
MEMBERS- A MINIMAL SO
CONTINGENCIES TAFT AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX.
FEET OF DISTANCE OF SPACING
THEY ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCE PROTOCOL FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE WHO HERE
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME ONCE PUBLIC
COMMENT BEGINS IF ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROME WISHES
TO SPEAK THEY WILL RAISE THEIR
HANDS AND WILL AND I WILL ASK
THEM TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. I WOULD ASK THAT
THE PUBLIC RESPECT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING GUIDELINES AND NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE YOU WILL
HAVE ONLY ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE PUBLIC
COMMENT IS DONE FOR RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT BUT PLEASE OBSERVE
FISCAL DISTANCING LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATED USED TO WANT AT A TIME.
WE WILL BE YOU MOLD. SIR FOR
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION.
INSTRUCTIONS FOR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION WAS PROVIDED IN
ADVANCE ON THE AGENDA THAT WAS
POSTED PUBLICLY ON MAY
FIFTEENTH. WHICH YOU CAN FIND
ON THE ASSEMBLY SUBCOMMITTEE
FIVE WEBSITE. OUR CALL IN
NUMBER IS. 1-877-692-8957 I'LL
REPEAT THAT ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS TWO TWO EIGHT THREE FOUR
THREE EIGHT. THE ACCESS CODE IS
TWO EIGHT THREE FOUR THREE
EIGHT. THIS IS ALSO ON THE
AGENDA POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE.
EACH PERSON WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND I
WILL STRICTLY ENFORCE THE RULES.
THOSE WATCHING THIS HEARING
REMOTELY SHOULD KNOW THAT THAN
LIVE STREAM HAS A LITTLE SLIGHT
DELAY FROM THAT BROADCAST TO
THE ACTUAL EVENT GOING ON IN
THE WORLD. IF YOU ARE CALLING
IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE LIKE YOUR
BROADCAST LIVE STREAM OR REDUCE
THE SOUNDEST DISTORTIONS. YOU
CAN ALSO CALL THE COMMITTEE AT.
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO NINE NINE. IT'S.
916-319-2099 IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS AND MY STAFF WILL
BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP. WILL
BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENTS AFTER ALL
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
CONCLUDED THEIR QUESTIONS. BOB
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN Q. WHEN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD BEGINS. ALSO TO
NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN FEEDBACK AT BUDGET SUB
FIVE. AT ASM DOT CA DOT GO
THAT'S BUDGET SUB FIVE AT A S.
M. DOT CA DOT GOV WHICH IS THE
EMAIL ACCOUNT. TODAY'S HEARING
WILL WILL. WILL RESERVE MOST OF
THE TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS TO
BE GET FEEDBACK FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE COMMUNITY
ON THEIR CONCERNS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ISSUES
BEFORE THIS SUBCOMMITTEE. I
WOULD ALLOW ALL MEMBERS TO BE
OPENINGS COMMENTS THEN TURNED
TO THE PRESS OUR PANELISTS WILL
HAVE ONE PANEL TODAY TO DISCUSS
THE VARIOUS MAY REVISION%
PROPOSALS. THE LA ALL WILL
PROVIDE US WITH AN OVERVIEW THE
PROPOSAL AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WILL PROVIDE BRIEF
COMMENTS IN RESPONSE IF THEY
WISH. ONCE THAT PANEL HAS
CONCLUDED WE WILL HAVE MANY WHO
HAVE MEMBER QUESTIONS AT THE
CONCLUSION OF THE MEMBER
QUESTIONS I WILL OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. I WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM THOSE IN
THE ROOM AND THEN OPEN IT UP TO
THE PUBLIC ON THE PHONE. I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL IN ADVANCE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AS WE ADJUSTING
TO THIS NEW FORMAT. I SHOULD
ALSO LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT WE
WILL NOT BE VOTING ON ANY ITEMS
TODAY TO THAT OF THE I THINK IN
SOME COMMITTEES THEY MAY HAVE
BEEN IN THE SENATE BUT THERE
ARE NO VOTES THAT WILL BE TAKEN
STAY ON ANY PARTICULAR ITEM SO
ALL IN. ALL ALL ITEMS ARE FOR
INFORMATION. AND HAVING BEEN
SAID I WANT TO ACCESS IT WITH
HER TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WEBER HERE. JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY KILEY. STONE HERE. OKAY
WE'RE ALL HERE THAT'S GREAT.
OKAY THE MEMBER VISION BUDGET
AND KNOWLEDGE IS THE NEW FISCAL
REALITY FOR THE STATE. LUCKILY
FOR OUR STATE. THE YEARS OF
BUILDING A RAINY DAY BUDGET.
WILL HELP TO ADDRESS SOME OF
OUR NEEDS BECAUSE THAT RAINY
DAY HAS CERTAINLY COME. EVEN SO
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
FORECASTED A FIFTY PLUS MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET HOLE AND NO
GUARANTEE OF SUFFICIENT FEDERAL
FUNDING. ESOS THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES CUTS TRIGGER CUTS AND
AUGMENTATIONS. ARE SUBCOMMITTEE
WILL THOROUGHLY REVIEW EACH OF
THESE PROPOSED TO ASSESS THEIR
POTENTIAL IMPACT AND THEIR
NECESSITY. IT'S GOING TO BE
GONE BECAUSE THE FOCUS IS
TRYING TO GIVE AS MUCH TIME TO
OF THOSE WHO ARE ON THIS IS THE
ONLY HEARING THAT WILL TAKE
PLACE FOR THE PUBLIC- FOR THEM
TO HAVE INPUT INTO IT WE'RE
GOING TO I'M GOING TO RESERVE
MIKE- COMMENTS FOR. ANOTHER
TIME AS WELL AS TO MAKE
COMMENTS AFTER WE HAVE OUR
PRESENTATION FROM MY PANELISTS
AND ASK QUESTIONS BUT I WILL
OPEN IT UP TO ANY MEMBER WHO
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A COMMENT AT
THIS TIME WE'RE ASKING THAT YOU
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO THREE
MINUTES. DOES ANYONE OKAY
MISTER JONES SAWYER WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE A STATEMENT. I WANT TO
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THIS
HEARING AND ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THERE MAY TIME TO
JOIN US TODAY- THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY A UNIQUE AND
CHALLENGING YEAR FROM A BUDGET
PERSPECTIVE. IT HAS BEEN SAID
MANY TIMES BUT BEARS REPEATING
THE BUDGET IS A REFLECTION OF
OUR VALUES. THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF ITEMS PROPOSED INTO MAY
REVISE THAT I'M PLEASED ABOUT
INCLUDING THE PLAN TO EX TO
EXPAND A GOOD. CONDUCT CREDIT
SYSTEM AND MOVING THE YOUTH OUT
OF THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND INTO COUNTY
PROGRAMS. I SUPPORT THE INTENT
OF THE PLANT TO CAP PAROLE AT
TWO YEARS IN ORDER TO
ACCELERATE THE DELIVERY OF
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. HOWEVER I
REMAIN CONCERNEDABOUT PROPER
IMPLEMENTATION AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AND ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE SURE
SURE THAT THIS IS DONE
PROPERLY. SIMILARLY WITH THE
PROPOSAL TO CLOSE PRESENCE I'M
ALL FOR SHRINKING THE SIZE OF
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
BUT I'M INTERESTED TO SEE THE
PROPOSED PLAN INCLUDING
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR LABOR
PARTNERS. FINALLY THERE ARE
SOME PLACES WHERE I WAS NOT A
SUPPORTIVE. OF THE MAY REVISED
PROPOSALS IN PARTICULAR TO
PROPOSAL TO REPORT. FIFTEEN
MILLION FROM THE U. HREE
INVESTMENT GRANT. AND THE
TRIBAL YOUTH REINVESTMENT GRANT
BACK INTO THE GENERAL FUND. WAS
CONCERNING TO ME. FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS THE LEGISLATURE ANY
ADMINISTRATION HAVE AGREED THAT
FUNDING SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR
YOUTH. IN LIEU OF INCARCERATION
WITH A PRIORITY. IT MAKES
ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE TO ME THAT
IN A YEAR WHERE WE ARE
PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE. STATE
INCARCERATION OF YOUTH WOULD
ALSO CUT THE VERSION FUNDING.
THESE FUNDS KEEP YOUTH OUT OF
PRISONS. WHICH REPRESENTS
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS TO THE
STATE BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY.
INVEST IN OUR YOUTH WITH
HEALTH. EDUCATION CAREER AND
OTHER IMPORTANT SERVICES. LAST
YEAR TO GRANT FUNDS WERE OVER
SERVE SUBSCRIBED WITH MORE
APPLICANTS THAN WE HAD MONEY
FOR. AND WE EXPECTED. THE SAME
WITH THE SAME WILL BE THE CASE
THIS YEAR. I STRONGLY SUPPORT A
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET. THAT
RETURNS THESE CRITICAL FUNDS
AND THAT SENTIMENT IS SHARED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROMMEL'S WHO
ADVOCATED FOR THE TRIBAL YOUTH
FUNDS. HE PLANS TO SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THIS COMMITTEE. ON
THIS IS ISSUE BUT I WILL READ
JUST A PORTION TODAY. A IME
WHEN THIS HAS APPROVED THIS
MONEY TO START TO DEAL WITH
YEARS OF NEGLECT. TO NOW PULL
BACK TO FUNDING REPLACED THE
MESSAGE OF PAST PRACTICES
TOWARD THE NATIVE YOUTH AND
INDIAN COMMUNITIES. THE TRIBAL
YOUTH DIVERSION PROGRAM IS A
KEY INVESTMENT IN OUR YOUTH AND
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BECOME A
VITAL PART OF OUR STATE
JUVENILE JUSTICE PROGRAMMING.
TO REDUCE CURRENT AND FUTURE
INCARCERATION AND PROBATION
COSTS FOR COUNTIES. ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS
AND JUSTICE INVOLVE YOU STATE
WHY I REQUEST TO FIFTEEN
MILLION FOR YOU THREE
INVESTMENT GRANTS BE RETURNED
TO THE BUDGET. THANK YOU MEANT
THAT MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE MRS DON'T. JUST
BRIEFLY I DIDN'T KNOW IF NOW IS
THE BEST TIME OR AFTER THE
PRESENTATION BUT I'LL JUST MAKE
A COUPLE COMMENTS ON AREAS THAT
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
WITH RESPECT TO THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH BUDGET I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE SIGNIFICANT CUTS THAT ARE
THERE AND NOT BUT I LOOK AT THE
MODERNIZATION FUNDS AND I KNOW
THIS IS BEEN A LONG DESIRE OF
THE- CHIEF JUSTICE AND JUDICIAL
COUNCIL BUT I JUST CAN'T HELP
BUT THINK THAT GIVEN THE
SACRIFICE THAT. WERE MAKING
ACROSS THE BOARD THAT
PRESERVING SOME OF THOSE MONIES
INSTEAD OF HOLDING OFF ON SOME
OF THAT MODERNIZATION. AND
SPENDING IT ON. ATTACKING
ACCESS TO JUSTICE THROUGH LEGAL
SERVICES WOULD BE PROBABLY
BETTER SERVED AT THIS POINT IN
TIME. AND THE SECOND COMMENT IS
WITH RESPECT TO DJJ WE'VE BEEN
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION FOR
QUITE SOME TIME ABOUT MOVING
AWAY FROM DJJ GIVING MORE
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE COUNTIES.
SO WHAT I WAS VERY INTERESTED
IN THE PROPOSAL. THAT'S IN THIS
BUDGET. AND I KNOW IT'S BEEN
BUILT AROUND SAVING SOME MONEY
AND THAT'S FINE. BUT AS WE SAID
THIS ESPONSIBILITY TO THE
COUNTIES WHICH I AGREE WITH
THAT I TRUST OUR PROBATION
CHIEFS TO. MANAGE THIS
APPROPRIATELY. THERE ARE SOME
PROGRAMMING. OPTIONS THAT DJJ
HAS HAD THAT I WOULD HATE TO
LOSE TO THIS PROCESS AND SO
WHAT THAT MEANS IS I THINK THE
STATE NEEDS TO KEEP. INVOLVED
WITH WHAT HAPPENS AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL AND WITH DESPERATE
RESOURCES AND DISPARATE PUBLIC
POLITICAL WILL IN OUR VARIOUS
COUNTIES. I WOULD HATE IF WE
SET UP A SITUATION WHERE THE
SUCCESS OF A KID IF OF A CHILD.
IN OUR JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
NOW BEING RUN BY THE COUNTIES
WOULD DEPEND ON WHICH COUNTY
THEIR RED SO THE STATE WILL
HAVE A CONTINUING ROLE. IN
MANAGING. OUTCOMES FOR KIDS AT
THE COUNTY LEVELS AND ENSURING
THAT THAT ALL KIDS IN WHATEVER
COUNTY THERE IN HAVE ACCESS TO
BASIC MINIMUM TYPES OF
PROGRAMS. THAT HELP THEM TO NOT
RECIDIVIST THAT HELP THEM GET
BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY AND
THAT WE THAT WE THEN SUPPORT
THE VARIOUS. PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY IN THAT WAY TO SUPPORT
THAT MOVE. BUT WITH A QUESTION
AS WITH EVERYTHING THAT DOUBLE
WILL BE IN THE DETAILS. AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND HOW THAT
GETS IMPLEMENTED AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE STATE STILL
MAINTAINS AN APPROPRIATE ROLE
IN PROTECTING KIDS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. EVEN AS WE KEEP
THEM LOCALLY WHICH WE KNOW
BENEFITS. CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES BY KEEPING THOSE KIDS
IS CLOSE TO HOME IS THAT
POSSIBLE SO- HEARTENED BY THE
PROPOSAL. AND I KNOW IT'S
BUDGETARY REALLY DRIVEN. BUT
IT'S ALSO GOOD POLICY IF WE
MANAGE THAT POLICY
APPROPRIATELY THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE. OKAY WE WILL NOW GO TO
OUR PANELISTS DREW SEIDENBERG
FROM THE LA OLD TO PROVIDE US
WITH AN OVERVIEW AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION-
IF THEY FEEL OF SOUL AND WE ARE
ALSO AVAILABLE FOR Q. NA. OKAY.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS- JURY
SHOULD WORK LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR INVITING US TO SPEAK
TODAY TODAY I WILL BE
PRESENTING FROM THIS HAND OUT
WHICH YOU SHOULD HAVE IN FRONT
OF YOU AND IT PROVIDES AN
OVERVIEW OF THE MAJOR PUBLIC
SAFETY PROPOSALS. IN THE-
TWENTY TWENTY ONE MAY REVISION.
IF YOU TURN TO THE FIRST PAGE
OF THE HANDOUT YOU'LL SEE A
TABLE DEPICTING THE CHANGE
BETWEEN JANUARY AND MAY FOR
SOME OF THE LARGER DEPARTMENTS
THAT WILL BE DISCUSSING TODAY.
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES
NUMEROUS PROPOSALS TO ADDRESS
THE FISCAL CRISIS FACING THE
STATE FOR EXAMPLE IT INCLUDES
PROPOSALS TO REVERT- REQUESTS
MADE IN JANUARY AS WELL AS TO
REDUCE THE SIZE OF THE REQUESTS
MADE IN JANUARY. THE GOVERNOR
ALSO PROPOSES VARIOUS
REDUCTIONS IN THE BASELINE
LEVEL OF FUNDING FOR SOME
DEPARTMENTS SUCH AS THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH. AS WELL AS
LOANS FROM NUMEROUS SPECIAL
FUNDS FROM THE DEPARTMENTS WILL
BE SPEAKING ABOUT TODAY. IF YOU
TURN TO THE NEXT PAGE YOUR HAND
OUT YOU'LL SEE AN OVERVIEW OF
THE JUST JUDICIAL BRANCH- I
WOULD KNOW BEFORE YOU GO INTO
THIS PRESENTATION I'VE BEEN
ASKED BY YOUR STAFF TO COMPLETE
ALL OF A OUR COMMENTS FOR EACH
OF THE DEPARTMENTS BEFORE
HANDING IT OVER- TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF THAT
WORKS FOR. YOU SO TO BEGIN WITH
USUAL BRANCH. ALL MY FIRST THE
MAY REVISION REDUCES FUNDING
FOR BASE OPERATIONS IT DOES
THIS BOTH BY WITHDRAWING A
PROPOSED A HUNDRED AND SEVEN
POINT SIX MILLION. DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND BASED AUGMENTATION
THAT WAS PROPOSED IN JANUARY.
AND MAKING A REDUCTION OF TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS- AN ON GOING
TRIGGER REDUCTIONS TO THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH. THESE
REDUCTIONS- WOULD BE ALLOCATED
TO THE TRIAL COURT'S HO WOULD
RECEIVE A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
REDUCTIONS. TWENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN REDUCTIONS
TO THE STATE COURTS WHICH IN
WHICH INCLUDE THE SUPREME
COURT. THE COURTS OF APPEALS
AND JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND
FIFTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN REDUCTIONS. TO
VARIOUS PROGRAMS AND THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH SUCH AS
DEPENDENCY COUNCIL- GIVEN THE
GENERAL FUND CONDITION FACING
THE STATE WE RECOMMEND
APPROVING THESE HOWEVER. WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ENSURE THAT THESE REDUCTIONS
REFLECT ITS PRIORITIES. FOR
EXAMPLE AT A MINIMUM WITH
RESPECT TO THE TRIAL COURT%
REDUCTION WE WOULD RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE DIRECT
THAT IT BE ALLOCATED BASED ON
WORKLOAD TO ENSURE THAT COURTS
THAT HAVE. MORE WORK LOAD
RELATIVE TO THEIR RESOURCES
RECEIVE SMALLER REDUCTIONS SO
THAT THE IMPACT ON THE PUBLIC
WILL BE LESS. THE LEGISLATURE
COULD ALSO CONSIDER OTHER
MODIFICATIONS SUCH AS
REQUIREMENTS THAT REDUCTIONS BE
ARE TARGETED SUCH THAT-
BASELINE LEVELS OF SERVICE ARE
PRESERVED. THE NEXT PROPOSAL IS
AN INCREASE IN THE LEVEL OF
GENERAL FUND BACK FILL PROVIDED
TO TRIAL COURTSTO OFFSET THE
REDUCTION AND FINES AND FEES
SPECIFICALLY THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A ONE TIME TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
BACK FILL THIS IS AN INCREASE
OF TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION ABOVE THE
AMOUNT PROPOSED IN JANUARY. IN
ADDITION THE- LONG LANGUAGE IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
INCREASE THIS AMOUNT AS
NECESSARY- WE RECOMMEND
MODIFYING THIS PROPOSED
LANGUAGE SO THAT IT PARALLELS
THE NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS
FOR. EXPENDITURES THIS WOULD
ENSURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
INFORMED OF ANY REQUESTS RUN
AUGMENTATION TO THIS AMOUNT- IT
WOULD ALSO ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO KNOW WHETHER OR
NOT THOSE REQUESTS WERE
APPROVED AND PUT THE
LEGISLATURE IN A POSITION TO
REVIEW THOSE REQUESTS BEFORE
THEY ARE APPROVED WE WOULD ALSO
RECOMMEND REQUIRING A QUARTERLY
REPORT ON THE AMOUNT OF THE
AUGMENTATION PROVIDED. TO THE-
TRIAL COURTS IN ORDER TO
FURTHER INCREASE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE
OF THIS PROPOSAL. YOU TURN TO
YOUR NEXT PAGE. WE'LL ALL GO ON
TO DESCRIBE A PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND ONE TIME. GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT FOR TRIAL COURT
WORKLOAD BACKLOGGED DUE TO COPE
WITH NINETEEN- WELL A BACKLOG
CERTAINLY EXISTS BECAUSE OF THE
STOPS VARIOUS TRIAL COURTS OF
TAKEN IN REACTION TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN- IT IS UNCLEAR WHAT
THE SIZE OF THIS BACKLOG AS
ACCORDINGLY WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ONLY. APPROVE
THIS AFTER RECEIVING
INFORMATION ON THE SIZE OF THE
BACKLOG AS WELL AS THE FACTS
THE FUNDING WOULD HAVE AND HOW
IT WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED BETWEEN
THE TRIAL COURT'S. ON IN
ADDITION THE MAIN REVISION-
PROVIDES ON GOING FUNDING FOR
COURT MODERNIZATION PROJECTS
THIS WOULD BE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
FUNDING THAT JUDICIAL COUNCIL
COULD ALLOCATE. TO COURT
MODERNIZATION PROJECTS WE ALSO
NOTE THAT THE MAI REVISION
WITHDRAWS TO JANUARY
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PROPOSALS THAT TOTAL TO
SEVENTEEN POINT TWO MILLION.
WE'D RECOMMEND REJECTING THIS
PROPOSED AUGMENTATION AS WE
FEEL THAT PROJECTS RATHER THAN
BEING SELECTED BY JUDICIAL
COUNCIL WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
INVOLVEMENT SHOULD BE PUT
THROUGH THE NORMAL BUDGET
PROCESS SO THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN GO THROUGH. THE TYPICAL
VETTING PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE CONSISTENT WITH ITS
PRIORITIES AND APPROPRIATE. OF
FINELY IN THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
OF THE MAY REVISION SUSPENDS
NEW COURTHOUSE CONSTRUCTION THE
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSED FORTY
THREE POINT SIX MILLION IN ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND RESOURCES. TO
BEGIN THE DESIGN OF OVER OF
ABOUT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
NEW COURTHOUSE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
PURSUED OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS. THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO WITHDRAW THAT
AMOUNT- HOWEVER WE WOULD KNOW
THAT PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
PROJECTS WOULD CONTINUE TO BE
PURSUED. ALL WE WOULD RECOMMEND
THE APPROVING THE MAY PROPOSAL
TO WITHDRAW THESE FUNDS GIVEN
THE STATE OF THE GENERAL FUND.
IF YOU TURN TO THE NEXT PAGE IN
YOUR HAND OUT PAGE FOUR- WILL
GOING TO DISCUSS THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FROM
THERE A SERIES OF CHANGES IN
THE MAJOR REVISION RELATED TO
THE BUREAU OF FORENSIC
SERVICES- TO BEGIN WITH THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES A THIRTY FIVE
POINT EIGHT MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND BACK FILL. AGAIN
TO ADDRESS THE DECLINE IN
FINDING FEE REVENUE THIS TIME
THE FINE AND FEES SUPPORTING
THE BUREAU OF FORENSIC
SERVICES. IN ADDITION THE MAY
REVISION WITHDRAWS TO PROPOSALS
THAT WOULD HAVE SUPPORTED BFS
THIS INCLUDE SEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION FOR EQUIPMENT. AND
FACILITY MAINTENANCE AS WELL AS
A NINE POINT FIVE MILLION IN
ONE TIME FUNDS THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN USED TO BEGIN THE PROCESS
OF BUILDING A NEW FORENSIC
LABORATORY IN SACRAMENTO. WE
WOULD RECOMMEND APPROVING THE
BACKFIELD BUT AGAIN WE WOULD
MODIFY THE LANGUAGE SO THAT IT
PARALLELS ON IN THE
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
ON ANTICIPATED COSTS SIMILAR
TO. MY REMARKS WITH RESPECT TO
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH- WE ALSO
RECOMMENDED THAT THE LOCAL
AGENCIES THAT USE THE BUREAU OF
FORENSIC SERVICES. BE REQUIRED
TO PARTIALLY SUPPORT THE BUREAU
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT DOJ TO
BEGIN. THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING A PLAN TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN. UNDER OUR PROPOSAL
THE GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR
THE BUREAU COULD BE REMOVED AND
INSTEAD REPLACED WITH SUPPORT
FROM THE- LOCAL ENTITIES THAT
RECEIVE BFS SERVICES FINALLY WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING THE
WITHDRAWAL OF THE OTHER BFS
JANUARY PROPOSALS. THE MAY
REVISION ALSO MAKES CHANGES TO
VARIOUS OTHER DOJ PROPOSALS FOR
EXAMPLE IT WITHDRAWS FIVE POINT
EIGHT MILLION GENERAL FUND
PROPOSAL FOR TAX RECOVERY TASK
FORCES. AND WITHDRAWS TWO POINT
TWO MILLION- THE ENTIRE GENERAL
FUND AMOUNT THAT WOULD HAVE
SUPPORTED THE HEALTH CARE
RIGHTS AND ACCESS SECTION THAT
SECTION- WILL CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE SIX POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN SPECIAL FUNDS
SUPPORT. AGAIN WE'D RECOMMEND
APPROVING THESE PROPOSALS GIVEN
THE CONDITION OF THE GENERAL
FUND. IN ADDITION THERE ARE
VARIOUS LOANS PROPOSED FROM DOJ
SPECIAL FUNDS- THEY TOTAL A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS INCLUDING A
LOAN FROM THE GAMBLING CONTROL
FUND OF EIGHTY MILLION AND A
LOAN FROM THE FINGERPRINT FEES
ACCOUNT A FIFTY MILLION. TOOK A
GOOD THESE BONDS AND BE THAT
THEY CAN SYSTEM THESE LAW AND-
THAT THESE LOANS BE APPROVED.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE FIVE OF
YOUR HAND OUT. OF WILL DISCUSS
SOME OF THE MAJOR PROPOSALS
RELATED THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. TO BE AN WITH. THE
MAY REVISION MAINTAINS FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
INCREASE FOR- THE COMMUNITY
POWER RESILIENCY FINDING THESE
ARE FUNDS THAT ARE USED TO
SUPPORT STATE AND LOCAL EFFORTS
TO MITIGATE THE EFFECTS OF
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER HUT OFFS.
BUT WE WOULD RECOMMEND
CONSIDERING REDUCING THIS
FUNDING GET GIVEN THE CONDITION
OF THE GENERAL FUND AND THE
LACK OF INFORMATION ON HOW
THESE FUNDS WOULD BE USED FOR
EXAMPLE AT THIS TIME IT'S
UNCLEAR HOW MUCH WOULD BE USED
BY THE STATE AND HOW MUCH WOULD
BE USED BY LOCALS HOWEVER IF
THE LEGISLATURE DOES DECIDE TO
APPROVE THIS OUT WE WOULD
RECOMMEND ADOPTING LANGUAGE.
SPECIFYING HOW THE FUNDS COULD
BE USED AND REQUIRING- YES TO
REPORT ON HOW THE FUNDS
ULTIMATELY ARE USED AND WHAT
OUTCOMES ARE ACHIEVED WITH NOTE
THAT SIMILAR FUNDING WAS
APPROVED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY AND THIS LANGUAGE PART
OF THAT FUNDING SO IT'S BEING
PER FOR TWO ONE. IN ADDITION
THE MAY REVIEW PROPOSES A
THIRTY EIGHT POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
INCREASE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DISASTER ASSISTANCE ACT- THIS
IS TWENTY ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION MORE THAN PROPOSED IN
JANUARY TO REIMBURSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. FOR CERTAIN COSTS
THIS IS SO SEATED WITH
EMERGENCY RESPONSE- WE WOULD
KNOW THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS INDICATED THAT THESE
DOLLARS COULD BE USED FOR
COVERT NINETEEN RELATED COSTS.
WE RECOMMEND APPROVING THESE
DOLLARS HOWEVER WE WOULD ALSO
RECOMMEND IMPROVING LANGUAGE
THAT REQUIRES- YES TO NOTIFY
THE LEGISLATURE WHEN THESE
FUNDS ARE BEING USED FOR COVERT
NINETEEN PURPOSES. IN ORDER TO
HELP THE LEGISLATURE BETTER
TRACK EXPENDITURES ON CODE
NINETEEN WHICH IS PROVED
DIFFICULT AT TIMES. IN ADDITION
BE MAY REVISION WITH DRAWS A
HUNDRED POINT EIGHT MILLION
FOR- YES TO IMPLEMENT THE HOME
HARDENING PILOT GRANT PROGRAM
THIRTY EIGHT LAST YEAR- WE'D
ALSO NOTE THAT THE MAI
REVISION. REDUCES THE FUNDING
FOR CAL FIRE TO IMPLEMENT THIS
BILL AS WELL WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
WHETHER REMOVING FUNDING FOR
THIS RECENTLY APPROVED BILL IS
APPROPRIATE. GIVEN ITS OTHER
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES AS WELL
AS THE CONDITION OF THE GENERAL
FUND WE WOULD NOTE THAT OF THAT
A HUNDRED POINT EIGHT MILLION-
ONLY TWENTY FIVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION OF IT IS GENERAL FUND.
IF YOU TURN TO THE NEXT PAGE
THAT WE WILL GO THROUGH- THE
FOR THE FINAL- PROPOSALS REALLY
TO THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. ON THE MAY REVISION
REDUCES FROM TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION TO TWO MILLION FUNDING
FOR THE WILD FIRE FOR CAST AND
THREATEN TELLIGENT INTEGRATION
CENTER. WHICH WAS AUTHORIZED BY
SB TWO OH NINE LAST YEAR IN
ADDITION IT PROPOSES LANGUAGE
REQUIRING DO LEFT TO APPROVE A
STRATEGY AND SPENDING PLAN
PRIOR TO- YES BEING ABLE TO
EXPAND FUNDS FOR THIS PURPOSE.
WE WOULD RECOMMEND APPROVING
THE REDUCTION GIVEN THE GENERAL
FUND CONDITION BUT WE WOULD
RECOMMEND MODIFYING IT TO
REQUIRE- WE US TO NOT ONLY
PROVIDE- IT THE STRATEGY AND
SPENDING PLAN TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE BUT ALSO TO THE
LEGISLATURE. VISION ALSO
MAINTAINS NINE POINT FOUR
MILLION IN DISASTER PLANNING
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE
FUNDING- OF THIS AMOUNT NINE
POINT TWO MILLION AS GENERAL
FUND THIS- THESE FUNDS ARE
SLATED TO BE USED TO SUPPORT.
FIFTY POSITIONS THAT WOULD HELP
SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT IN
VARIOUS AREAS SUCH AS FINANCE
ADMINISTRATION AND DISASTER
RESPONSE. WE WOULD RECOMMEND
CONSIDERING APPROVING THIS
FUNDING OLY ON A ONE TIME
BASIS WHILE THE DEPARTMENT IS
CERTAINLY- EXPERIENCING- HIGH
LEVELS OF WORKLOAD RELATED TO
CODE NINETEEN AND OTHER
DISASTERS IT'S UNCLEAR HOW LONG
THIS WORK LOAD WILL EXIST SO BY
APPROVING IT ON A LIMITED TERM
BASIS THE LEGISLATURE CAN
REASSESS. WHETHER THIS LEVEL OF
FUNDING IS APPROPRIATE OR
FURTHER MODIFICATIONS ARE
NECESSARY ONCE IT EXPIRES. OF
FINELY THE- MAY REVISION
REVERTS FUNDING FOR VARIOUS
LEGISLATIVE AUGMENTATIONS MADE
IN RECENT YEARS FOR EXAMPLE IT
REVERTS FUNDING- FOR THE
INTERNET CRIMES AGAINST
CHILDREN PROGRAM- THESE
VERSIONS ARE BEING PURSUED-
BECAUSE NOT ALL OF THE FUNDS
THAT WERE ALLOCATED WERE SPENT-
WE WOULD JUST KNOW THAT IT'S
UNCLEAR IN SOME CASES WHY THESE
FUNDS WERE SPENT PARTICULARLY
IN CASES WHERE SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS WERE PRETTY WELL
ESTABLISHED. SUCH AS THE
INTERNET CRIMES AGAINST
CHILDREN PROGRAM. IF YOU TURN
TO PAGE SEVEN OF THE HAND OUT.
YOU'LL SEE- THE PROPOSAL'S
RELATED TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. THE NAY
REVISION PROPOSES VARIOUS
POPULATION REDUCTION MEASURES
AS WELL AS PRISON CLOSURES
SPECIFICALLY IT PROPOSES TO
REDUCE RECEPTION CENTER
PROCESSING TIME IN ORDER TO GET
INMATES INTO THE MAIN LINE
PRISONS THEY LIVE THAT FASTER
SO THAT THEY CAN BEGAN
PARTICIPATING IN PROGRAMS AND
EARNING CREDITS EARLIER. WHICH
WOULD REDUCE THE PRISON
POPULATION IT ALSO PROPOSES TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT CERTAIN INMATES EARN
THROUGH GOOD BEHAVIOR TO
FURTHER REDUCE THE PRISON
POPULATION IN TOTAL THE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES THESE
CHANGES WOULD REDUCE THE INMATE
POPULATION BY ELEVEN THOUSAND
INMATES BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR. IN LIGHT OF THE
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES TO CLOSE ONE
PRISON AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND ANOTHER AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
HOWEVER THE PRISONS THAT WOULD
BE CLOSE ARE NOT IDENTIFIED AT
THIS TIME. THESE CHANGES WOULD
CREATE SIX POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS AND SAVINGS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AND HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL SAVINGS IN FUTURE
YEARS ONCE THE PRISONS ARE
CLOSED. WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
POPULATION REDUCTIONS WHAT OUT
LIKELY ALLOW THE FOR THE STATE
TO CLOSE MORE THAN JUST TO
PRISON SPECIFICALLY DEPENDING
ON THE SIZE OF THE PRISONS
SELECTED FOR CLOSURE THE STATE
COULD CLOSE ONE TWO FIVE
ADDITIONAL PRISONS. ON TOP OF
THE TO PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE NUMBER OF
PRISONS THAT COULD BE SLATED
FOR CLOSURE WE'D RECOMMEND
DIRECTING CDC ARE. TO RANK
PRISONS FOR CLOSURE BASED ON
CRITERIA SPECIFIED BY THE
LEGISLATURE SUCH AS THEIR
OPERATING COSTS PER BAD. WE
ALSO RECOMMEND NOT APPROVING
PRISON INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
INTEL SPECIFIC PRISONS FOR
CLOSURE ARE IDENTIFIED. THIS
WOULD ALSO GIVE THE LEGISLATURE
MORE TIME TO ASSESS THE IMPACT
OF THE POPULATION CHANGES ON
THE NEED FOR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ENSURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DOES NOT APPROVE-
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AT
PRISONS THAT WILL ULTIMATELY BE
CLOSED. THE MAY REVISION ALSO
PROPOSES TO REDUCE THE PEARLY
POPULATION. ALL IT DOES THIS IN
TWO WAYS FIRST IT PROPOSES TO
CAP PAROLE TERMS FOR MOST
PAROLEES AT TWENTY FOUR MONTHS.
AND TO ESTABLISH AND EARNED
DISCHARGE PROCESS. THESE
CHANGES WOULD REDUCE THE PAROLE
POPULATION BY ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND AND CREATE TWENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
SAVINGS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
TO OUR- TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WITH TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AN INCREASE SAVINGS IN
FUTURE YEARS- WE KNOW THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD FOCUS RESOURCES
ON THE TIME PERIOD IN PAROLE
WHEN INDIVIDUALS ARE MOST
LIKELY TO VIOLATE. AND INCREASE
PAROLEES CENTER OF TO ADHERE TO
THE TERMS OF THEIR SUPERVISION.
ALSO NOTE PROPOSAL COULD
ACHIEVE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
FURTHER SAVINGS IF IT WAS
ADJUSTED TO ACCOUNT FOR US SOME%
OF THE OTHER SAVINGS THAT
OCCURS THROUGH THE REDUCTIONS
AND THE. VISUALS ON ELECTRONIC
MONITORING. IF YOU TURN THE
PAGE EIGHT YOU'LL SEE A
DISCUSSION OF THE REALIGNMENT
OF THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR-
PUT IN PLACE A PLAN THAT WOULD
HAVE TRANSITION THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE OUT OF CDC ARE
AND MAKE IT ITS OWN AND APART
INDEPENDENT DEPARTMENT THE
DEPARTMENT OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION. THE MAY
REVISION- CANCELS OUT
TRANSITION AND SCORES ROUGHLY
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
SAVINGS ASSOCIATED WITH FUNDING
PROVIDED FOR THAT TRANSITION.
IT ALSO PROPOSES TO REALIGN BJJ
TO COUNTY RESPONSIBILITY BY
STOPPING INTAKE OF NEW YOUTH TO
DJJ BEGINNING JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ALLOWING
DE JJ'S POPULATION TO DECLINE
THROUGH ATTRITION. THE BUDGET
ALSO PROVIDES COUNTIES FUNDING
TO HELP COVER THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH HOUSING USE WHO
WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN SENT
TO DJJ WHILE THESE CHANGES ONLY
CREATE ONE MILLION DOLLARS OF
NET SAVINGS IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THE ACTUAL CLOSURE OF DJJ
WOULD CREATE ADDITIONAL SAVINGS
IN FUTURE YEARS. WE WOULD
RECOMMEND APPROVING THIS
PROPOSAL AS IT'S GENERALLY
CONSISTENT WITH OUR PRIOR
RECOMMENDATIONS HOWEVER WE DO
RECOMMEND SEVERAL MODIFICATIONS.
SEPARATELY WE'D RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPT BUDGET
TRAILER LEGISLATION TO SET A
CONCRETE DATE FOR THE FULL
CLOSURE OF DJJ BY JUNE THIRTY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THAT THIS-
LANGUAGE ALLOW COUNTIES TO
CONTRACT WITH THE J. J. AT THE
FULL STATE COST TO ASSIST THEM
WITH THIS TRANSITION. THAT IT
INCENTIVIZE COUNTIES TO RECALL
DJJ WARDS BEFORE THAT FINAL
CLOSURE DATE AND THAT IT CALLS
ON BSE SEE TO. DO A STUDY OF
THE AMOUNT IT COSTS TO RUN AN
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THIS DATA WOULD BE
USED TO ESTABLISH THE
REALIGNMENT FUNDING FORMULA AND
THIS REPORT WOULD BE DUE FROM
THE SEC BY JULY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. IN ADDITION GIVEN THAT THE
ELIMINATION OF D. J. COULD HAVE
THE POTENTIAL OF INCREASING
THEM NOT THE NUMBER OF YOUTHS
CHARGED AS ADULT WE WERE TOLD.
WE'D RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED VARIOUS
STATUTORY CHANGES TO MITIGATE
THIS SITE INCREASING OF THE
JUVENILECOURTS- AGE OF
JURISDICTION FROM TWENTY ONE TO
TWENTY FIVE AND ALLOWING LOCAL
JUVENILE FACILITIES TO HOLD
USE- WHO ARE SENTENCED IN ADULT
COURT PRIOR TO THEM BEING
SPENT. TO CDC ARE WE ALSO LIKE
TO KNOW RESPECT TO CBC OURS
BUDGET THAT IN VERY IS IT IT IS
NOT ACCOUNT THE LAFAYETTE OF
KOBE NIGHT. FOR EXAMPLE CALL
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR IMPLEMENTED AT THE
INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT PRO I'M- IS
A VERY LARGE EXPANSION IN THE
BILL. HEALTH PROGRAMS IN THE
SENS IT WAS SO TO END BY NINETY
ONE MAY DOLLARS BETWEEN NOW. TO
AND THE BUDGET YEAR THE NAY
REVISION INCLUDES THIS NINETY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO STOP
DESPITE THE FACT THAT MANY OF
pBEING CURTAILED DUE TO PHYSICAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS. GIVEN
THIS WE THINK IT'S UNLIKELY
THAT THE FULL NINETY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS WILL BE
NECESSARY AND RECOMMEND A MORE
MODEST EXPANSION OF ONLY FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WHICH
WOULD CREATE FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN SAVINGS. IN ADDITION
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS ABOVE
THE ROUGHLY SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR BASE BUDGET FOR MEDICAL
GUARDING AND TRANSPORTATION-
HOWEVER AGAIN DUE TO VISIT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
WITHIN THE PRISONS THERE- FEWER
MEDICAL TRANSPORTS OUTSIDE OF
PRISONS IN WITHIN PRISONS AND
SO E THINK IT'S LIKELY THAT
SOME OR ALL OF THAT FOURTEEN
MILLION. DOLLAR INCREASE ON THE
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR BASE
BUDGET WON'T BE NECESSARY. OF
FINELY THERE OBVIOUSLY VARIOUS
CASELOAD ADJUSTMENTS ON THESE
CASELOAD ADJUSTMENTS HOWEVER
HAVE NOT BEEN ADJUSTED AGAIN TO
ACCOUNT FOR CODE NINETEEN
ACCORDINGLY WE'D RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTED THE
DEPARTMENT. TO DO FISCAL AND
CASE LOAD ESTIMATES TO BE
RELEASED BY OCTOBER ONE TWENTY
TWENTY THAT DO REFLECT THE
AFFECTS OF NINETEEN. SO NOW IF
YOU TURN TO PAGE TEN OF YOUR
HAND OUT WILL DISCUSS A FINALS
US SOME OTHER NOTABLE PROP-
PROPOSALS IN THE MAY REVISION
RELATED TO PUBLIC SAFETY- WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE MAI
REVISION REMOVES FUNDING THE
EXPAND. OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL. AS YOU'LL RECALL THE
LEGISLATURE IMPLEMENTED
LEGISLATION ALLOWING- IG TO
INITIATE AUDITS REVIEWS AND
INVESTIGATIONS ON ITS OWN AND
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
ENABLE IT TO DO SO THE MAY
REVISION ELIMINATES THIS
FUNDING WHICH WOULD LIKELY
LIMIT THE ABILITY OF THE O. I.
G. TO ENGAGE IN THESE
ACTIVITIES. THE MAY REVISION
ALSO PROPOSES TWELVE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR COUNTY
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH INMATES
BEING RELEASED EARLY FROM
PRISON TO THE SUPERVISION OF
COUNTY PROBATION- WELL THE
STATE IS TYPICALLY PROVIDED
THIS FUNDING TO OFFSET THE
SHORT TERM INCREASING COSTS
THEY EXPERIENCE WHEN THESE
EARLY RELEASES OF HER. THE
STATE IS NOT OBLIGATED TO DO SO
AS THESE COSTS WILL BE OFFSET
BY FUTURE SAVINGS ARE GIVEN THE
STATE'S FISCAL CONDITION WE
RECOMMEND THAT THIS TWELVE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS BE
ELIMINATED. FINALLY WE ALSO
NOTE THAT THE MAI REVISION
MAKES VARIOUS- CHANGES TO
PROGRAMS OFFERED BY THE PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING
THE COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING. IT
PROPOSES TO REPORT PROCREATE.
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN UNSPENT
ONE TIME GENERAL FUNDS- SUPPORT
PROVIDED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THAT SUPPORTED
INCREASED DISTANCE LEARNING
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES IT ALSO
PROPOSES TO REVERT SIXTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION IN UNSPENT
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES. APPROPRIATED IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN FOR
IMPLICIT BIAS AND PROCEDURAL
DRESSED JUSTICE TRAINING-
APPROPRIATED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FOR USE OF FORCE- OR
CRISIS MENTAL HEALTH TRAINING.
AS WELL AS LOCAL ASSIST FINDING
PROVIDED IN THE NINETEEN
TWENTY. WE KNOW THAT THE
REAPPROPRIATION OF THE TEN
MILLION FOR DISTANCE LEARNING
COULD. EXPAND HOW THE STATE
PROVIDES TRAINING TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WELL THE REVISIONS
WOULD HELP ADDRESS THE VISION
OF THE J. ONE BUT- WE NEED TO
WAIT. LET PRIOR TO A OF THESE
PROGRAMS. HI WITHOUT I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS OR TURN
IT OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF.
YOU WILL HEAR FROM. TIONS
BERMAN FINANCE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR STEVEN BANDS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'LL JUST
HAVE MAKE A FEW COMMENTS-
ACROSS VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS ON
THE NOTE THAT I DO HAVE FOR
COLLEAGUES IN THE ROOM WITH ME
SO THEY CAN PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
DETAIL OR QUESTIONS A GOOD GEN
I'M ANSWER. SO IN REGARDS TO
YEAH. ELIO WITH LOW ABOUT THE
COMMITTEE POWERS FUNDING I
WOULD AGREE THAT LAST YEAR'S A
BUDGET ACT DID- REQUIRE
REPORTING ON HOW THE FUNDING
WAS SPENT- WE'RE FINE WITH THAT
REQUIREMENT. BUT WE ARE OPPOSED
TO ADOPTING LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
REQUIRE HI BEING TOO
PRESCRIPTIVE IN ADVANCE AS TO
HOW THE FUNDING WILL BE SPLIT
AND USED. I THINK WE LEARNED
FROM LAST YEAR IS THAT IT'S
DIFFICULT TO PREDICT WITH ANY
LEVEL OF ACCURACY AND ADVANCE
EXACTLY. WILL BE THE MOST
PRESSING NEED DISEASE EVENTS TO
OCCUR. AND SO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL SHE
TRIES TO STRIKE A BALANCE
BETWEEN HAVING A PREPARED PLAN
FOR WHAT WE ARE INTENDING TO
DO. BUT ALSO PROVIDING
FLEXIBILITY SO THAT SPENDING
CAN DECISIONS CAN BE MADE IN
THE REAL TIME BASED ON THE
CONDITIONS THAT WE ACTUALLY
EXPERIENCE SO WE ARE OPPOSED TO
HAVING ANYTHING TOO
PRESCRIPTIVE- HAPPY TO CONTINUE
CALM. THE SHINS ABOUT HOW TO
STRIKE THAT BALANCE. IN REGARDS
TO THE CDAFUNDING JUST WANTED
TO NOTE THAT NONE OF THE
AUGMENTATION FUNDING THAT'S
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
IS RELATED TO PROVIDE NINETEEN.
ALL OF THAT IS ASSOCIATED WITH
STRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT
RESULTED FROM PRIOR DISASTERS
SUCH AS THE CAMPFIRE AND
VARIOUS OTHERS. AND THEN I
WANTED TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE- DISASTER PLANNING
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE FUNDING
AND JUST NOTE THAT- WERE
OPPOSED TO THE ALLEY OWES
RECOMMENDATION FOR LIMITED TERM
FUNDING UP IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO HIRE PERMANENT POSITIONS
WITH LIMITED TERM FOR AT. AND
THEN. THIS PROPOSAL. GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BEFORE YOU'RE COVERED
WORKLOAD WAS EVEN TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT SO THIS WORKLOAD ISN'T
ISN'T REALLY RELATED TO. HOW
MUCH ADDITIONAL- INFLUX THERE
IS FROM COVERT NINETEEN. THIS
IS BASED ON AN EVALUATION OF A
STUDY STATE NEEDED ON GO ON OUR
WORKLOAD AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
ART YES. AND THEN JUST ON THE
VERSION OF LEGISLATIVE
AUGMENTATIONS IT IS THE NO IT'S
JUST THAT IT'S UNCLEAR SOME OF
THIS IS DONE AND- REASONS WHY
SOME OF THIS FUNDING. HASN'T
GONE OUT YET OF STEP. BY YOUR
PROGRAM PROGRAM AND- KIND OF
DISCUSS THE SPECIFIC REVISIONS
WITH. STEP OR ARE. TO GET MORE
DETAIL THE SPACE WEAPONS. I'M
TALKING ABOUT SEE ARE A
POPULATION BECAUSE- YOU ARE NOT
THE POPULAR ADJUSTMENTS
INCLUDED IN THE MAYOR VERSION
WERE COMPLETED BEFORE COVERT
RELATED TO RESPONSE AND OTHER
CHANGES POPULAR TOOK PLACE. SO
BASED ON INITIAL ESTIMATES AND
THERE'S GOING TO BE OBVIOUSLY
CHANGES SINCE THE MAYOR VISION
AND YOU KNOW HAPPEN TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF.
THE JOB SINCE SIT. AS WE GO
THROUGH OUR REGULAR. FALL
UDGET BUILDING FOR IN REGARDS
TO PRISON CLOSURE IS ONE A NOT
THAT A NUMBER OF FACTORS THAT
HAVE TO BE CONSIDERED BEFORE
SELECT THAN A NUMBER OF FACTORS
NEED TO BE CONSIDERED BEFORE
SELECTING WHICH PERSONS ARE
CLOSED. KING PRISONS FOR
CLOSURE. MAY IMPACTS CITIES
YOURS ABILITY TO OPERATE THOSE
FACILITIES AND LIMIT ITS
ABILITY TO RECRUIT RETAIN
EMPLOYEES THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN FOR THE MINISTRATION.
ADDITIONALLY THE PROP CLOSE THE
MAYOR VISION WERE EITHER
EXISTING PROJECT SORRY. THE
PROJECT THE KAPLAN PROJECTS
PROPOSING MAYOR VISION WERE
EITHER EXISTING PROJECTS
ACTIVELY IN CONSTRUCTION PHASES%
OR PROJECTS THAT ARE NECESSARY
TO COMPLETE COMPLY WITH LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS PUBLIC SAFETY
NEEDS. CLOSER PORT CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD I WITH THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. IN REGARDS TO THE
MED GUARD SO THE ADMINISTRATION
IS OPPOSED TO ALIENS
RECOMMENDATION BASED ON THE
WORKLOAD PROJECTIONS AND
BACKLOG FOR SPECIFIC OR
SPECIALTY MEDICAL SERVICES. WE
ANTICIPATE THE WORKLOAD TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WAS
ASSUMED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. OF AND THEN IN REGARDS
TO GIGI ALIGNMENT- THIS IS A
PRIORITY PROJECT A PROPOSAL FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION- EXPANDS ON
ADMINISTRATIONS AND IT STATES
PREVIOUS SUCCESSFUL EFFORTS TO
ENABLE USED TO MAINTAIN THEIR-
TO REMAIN IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND STAY CLOSE TO THEIR
FAMILIES. WHICH IS SUPPORTIVE
OF THEIR REAL DILATATION
ACTIVITIES THE ADMINISTRATION'S
CONTINUING TO REFINE THIS
PROPOSAL AND LOOKS FORWARD TO
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS-
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH- LA
RECOMMENDATION SPECIFICALLY.
SETTING A DATE SPECIFIC FOR YOU
DJJ CLOSURE- AS WELL AS SETTING
MECHANISM FOR COUNTIES TO
CONTRACT WITH THE JUDGE IN THE
SHORT TERM. AND PROVIDING
INCENTIVES FOR COUNTIES TO
RECALL DJ WARDS BEFORE THE
FINAL CLOSURE DAY. WE BELIEVE
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS DID NOT
SUFFICIENTLY TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE UNCERTAINTY ASSOCIATED WITH
CLOSING LARGE FACILITIES. AND
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT ALLOWING
COUNTIES TO CONTRACT BACK WITH
THE J. J. COULD LEAD TO SOME
LOGISTIC CHALLENGES AS WELL AS
OTHER UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THAT COULD SLOW THE CLOSURE OF
G. JJ. DID YOU THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
SAKES. PSYCHIATRY REGISTRY
SERVICES AS WELL AS CONTINUED
FUNDING FROM THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT FOR THE
INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT PROGRAM.
BOTH OF WHICH ARE PRIORITY
ACTIVITIES FROM ADMINISTRATION
A SIGNIFICANT FOCUS OF THE
FEDERAL COURTS ANY REDUCTIONS
OR REMOVAL OF FUNDING FOR THESE
CRITICAL AREAS AS RECOMMENDED
BY THE AUDIO COULD INHIBIT THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE HEALTH CARE AS WELL AS
MEET FEDERAL COURT MANDATES. I
WITH THAT WERE HAPPY TO- TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. FROM THE FROM
THE MANY. THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK US BOTH OF YOU LA- AND
PART OF FINANCE FOR YOUR-
ANALYSIS AND DISCUSSION OF THE
MAY REVISION- I THINK WE HAVE-
AND I WANT TO THANK ILLEGAL AYE
I THINK YOU'VE RAISED A NUMBER
OF ISSUES THAT I HAD ACTUALLY
DONE A FIGHT ABOUT THE ISSUES
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS AND I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT- THE ISSUE OF
WHICH WE'VE DONE FOR. A NUMBER
OF YEARS THE ISSUE OF CLOSING
PRISONS. WE HAVE GONE THROUGH
THIS PROCESS FOR THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS. AND HAVE ASKED
FOR A PLAN. FROM CDC ARE. A
PRIORITY PLAN WE'VE SAID WE
DIDN'T WANT TO DO MAJOR
CONSTRUCTION OUR RENOVATIONS IF
WE DIDN'T KNOW. WHAT PRISON WAS
GOING TO BE CLOSED DOWN. AND WE
HAVE YET TO GET A PLAN WE HAVE
YET TO GET THE PRIORITY SO AND
TERMS OF. WHAT SHOULD BE THE
STANDARDS TO BE USED IN SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT MAYBE PUTTING
TOGETHER. THE PRIORITIES FOR
YOU- TO HELP MAKE THIS DECISION
BUT WE HAVE YET TO SEE A PLAN.
OF FROM- FROM CDC ARE
CONCERNING PRISON CLOSURES AND
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT
EXTENSIVELY. BY LEASE FOR THE
LAST TWO TO THREE YEARS. AND NO
ONE HAS COME FORWARD WITH THE
PLAN SO THAT IS A MAJOR PROBLEM
I THINK ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. A CAPITAL OUTLAY
AND THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
RESOURCES AND WE HAVE SAID VERY
CLEARLY. THE LAST THING WE WANT
TO DO IS PUT A BRAND NEW ROOF
ON A PRISON THAT WE TORE DOWN
SIX DOUBLE TEN OUT SIX MONTHS
LATER. AND HAVE THAT AS A PART
OF THE USE OF RESOURCES ARE
REALLY THAT THE USE OF
RESOURCES SO- IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US TO. IN THE
PLEASE FOR ME PERSONALLY I
SHOULD SAY TO TRUST THE CDC
ARE. IS CAPABLE OF MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT CULTURE
PRESENCE BECAUSE- OF THEIR
VESTED INTEREST IN MAINTAINING
PRISONS. SO IT'S A IT'S A AND
THE ISSUE. WE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME. TALKING ABOUT. THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL. AIR AND THE
POSITION THAT WE NEEDED TO HAVE
SOMEONE OVERSIGHT. AND WE
FUNDED IT TO HAVE OVERSIGHT. I
MEAN WHO BETTER TO TELL US
WHICH PRISON THESE TO BE CLOSE
IN THE INSPECTOR GENERAL. OF
SURELY NOT THE WARDENS TO TELL
US BUT SURELY THEY EXPECT THE
GENERAL IF THEY'RE IN AND OUT
OF OUR PRISONS. LOOKING AT THE
FACILITIES LOOKING AT THE
MAINTENANCE OF THINGS AND ALSO
HAVING AN UNDERSTANDING. OF
WHAT IS THERE. SO I FIND IT
VERY WELLPERSONALLY- DIFFICULT
FOR ME TO. CUT OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL F. WE SPEND SO MUCH
TIME TRYING TO REALIZE TO ONCE
AGAIN TO RESTORE THEM TO THE
POSITION OF. OVERSIGHT
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'VE HAD SO
MANY COMPLAINTS ABOUT IT WITHIN
OUR PRISONS THAT HAVE COME
FORWARD IN TERMS OF INDIVIDUALS
EITHER BEING TREATED. THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS WE CUT OUT THIS
IS ALSO CUTTING OUT THE
CAMERAS- IN THE PRISONS THAT TO
GIVE US SOME OVERSIGHT SOME
EYES AND EARS AND THERE THAT.
THAT SO IT SEEMS THAT THE-
VALUES THAT WE HAVE A SOMETIME
KNOW THAT MAYBE YOU CAN TELL US
WHY. HAVE BEEN KIND OF TOSSED
OUT THE WINDOW AND WE'RE BACK
TO SQUARE ONE WHERE YOU WERE
BEFORE. WANT TO KNOW WHY DJJ.
ASI SAID WE TALK ABOUT THE
COLLISION AND EVERYONE HEARS
AGREE THAT THAT. CLOSURE IS A
GOOD IDEA WHICH WE DID LAST
YEAR EXTENSIVELY IN HEARINGS.
WE HEARD FROM HOPE LOTS OF
COMMUNITY PEOPLE- TRY TO FORM
SOME KIND OF STRIP. BASIN TO DO
THAT. AND ACT SCREWED YEAH THE
PROJECT. BUT WITH. PROPOSED FOR
COMMUNITY PEOPLE SO AS I
MEMBERS OF ARE SORRY IS REALLY
THE PROCESS YOU KNOW WHAT IS A
PROCEDURE THAT'S GOING TO BE IN
ENGAGE THEM TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS A SAFE AND REASONABLE
TRANSITION OF FOR THE FOLKS IN
THE JJ SO I THINK THOSE THOSE
BECOME EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AS
WE TALK ABOUT. THE KINDS OF
GENERAL CUTS OF THE KIND OF
CUTS THAT ARE TAKING PLACE THAT
IS THE YEAR- I'VE BEEN ASKED
CLEARLY BY MY COLLEAGUES AS TO
WHY IT ALL OF THE OTHER AREAS
AND MAYBE YOU CAN ALSO ANSWER
THAT UNFORTUNATELY THE CDC IS
NOT HERE TO TELL ME WHAT CCC
OURS BUT IT IS THE SAME AS IT
WAS LAST. OF WITH THIS SHIFTING
AND- ELSE'S EXPERIENCE. MAJOR
CUTS AND WE SEE THAT THE- CDC
ARE HAS HAD PROBABLY ZERO CUTS.%
A WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BACK OF
PAGE. ONE WELL WE STARTED THE
AMOUNT OF THE PERCENTAGE OF
CHANGE. IS REALLY NEGLIGIBLE.
IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE. IN JANUARY
AND WHAT THEY HAVE NOW- STILL
THIRTEEN POINT SOME ODD BILLION
DOLLARS GOING INTO CDC ARE. A
WOULD SHIFT OUT AND IN TERMS OF
THINGS THAT WE VALUE. AND YEAH
WE GET UP IN THE SAME SPOT IN
TERMS OF MONEY. NO THAT OUR
SCHOOL PEOPLE ASKING WHY IS IT
THIS THE ONLY ENTITY. AND HAS
NOT EXPERIENCE ANY MADE CUTS
THAT ARE THERE. BLACK BUT YOU
ALSO SEE AND IS A I'M JUST
RAISING A THINK THAT ARE. WE TO
RAISE AS WE DECIDE WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO. AGREE TO AND WHAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO AGREE TO.
AND CLEARLY I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
A NUMBER OF THINGS ARE HOUSING
AND- AND FOLKS WHO LEAVING
PRISON WERE EXONERATED AND
STILL NOT GETTING RESOURCES
THAT ARE THERE. BUT YOU HAVE A
NUMBER OF THINGS THAT TRIGGER
CUTS AND SO. OR OR THAT
FINANCED THAT THAT FOR WHATEVER
REASON WOULD TRIGGER. NO CUTS
COULD YOU IN IN IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PARTICULARLY EXPLAIN TO US SO
WE CLEARED THE PUBLIC. WHAT IT
MEANS TO TALK ABOUT TRIGGERING
CUTS. OFF FROM THE BUDGET. NO
IN FINANCE WOULD WELL
SOMEBODY'S ON TAKE THAT YEAR
OKAY. COULD YOU TELL US WHAT IT
MEANS TO TRIGGER CUTS. WHAT
HAPPENS IN THAT PROCESS WHAT WE
NEED TO BE WATCHING OUT FOR.
SURE THIS CRYSTAL FURTHER WITH
THAT AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
ESSENTIALLY OF THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THIS ARE
PREPARING FOR THE EVENT IN
WHICH WE WERE TO RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL- FEDERAL FUNDS AND
SO. OBVIOUSLY THERE'S SOME
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT WHETHER WE
WILL RAISE THE IF I'M
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FINES WHAT
SORT OF PARAMETERS MAY BE
PLACED ON THOSE FEDERAL FUNDS
AND THEN ALSO AND- EACH WE PUT
TOGETHER THESE TRIGGERING BASS
REDUCTION- ISSUES FOR EACH OF
THE DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE SO- ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD
HAVE TO WAY. I'M WHICH OF THESE
TRIGGERS ESSENTIALLY RIGHTS TO-
UP PRIORITY I IN THE EVENT THAT
WE HAVE LIMITED AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT COME AND-
SO- I'M THAT BASS REDUCTION
TRIGGER LIVES ACROSS THESE
DEPARTMENTS. ARE SUBJECT TO
REFINEMENT SO THESE ARE
PRELIMINARY LISTED HAVE BEEN
PUT TOGETHER. ISSUES THAT. IN
THE EVENT FOR A FUNDS COME IN
WE COULD RESTORE SOME OF THESE
FUNDING LEVELS BUT AS I
MENTIONED THESE ARE SUBJECT TO
REFINEMENT AND ALL THE CAPULETS
AROUND THE ACTUAL FEDERAL FUNDS
AND HOW MUCH CONTENT. TO THEIR
NUMBER TRIGGERS THROUGHOUT NOT
ONLY IN OUR BUDGET BUT
THROUGHOUT THE OTHER BUT JUST
SO ARE YOU SAYING THAT THEY ALL
GET IN LINE. AND THEN WHO
DETERMINES WHO'S AT THE FRONT
OF THE LINE AT THE BACK OF THE
LINE. I'M I THINK THERE'S STILL
SOME UNCERTAINTY AROUND THAT
PROCESS- AND AGAIN THESE LIST
AREN'T. A FINAL AT THIS POINT
THEY'RE SUBJECT TO REFINEMENT
AND- AND CERTAINLY TO-
ENGAGEMENT- WITH THE UP WITH
THE APPROPRIATE THAT
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE
LEGISLATURE SO. I'M YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF THE THAT THE PROCESS
FOR. FOR WHO DETERMINES THAT I
THINK. I'M AGAIN. AND IT'LL BE
ANOTHER CONVERSATION I BASED ON
THE ON THE PRIORITIES AND
ULTIMATELY WHAT. I'M ACTIONS
ARE TAKEN. I'M IN THE IN THE
COMMITTEES. SO I ASSUME THAT I
WOULD HOPE THAT IT WOULD HAVE
AT LEAST A LIST OF PRIORITIES
ARE. SOME IDEA OF WHERE FOLKS
ARE IN THE IN THE LINE FOR CUTS
SO THEY'VE RESOURCES COME AND
IF THEY DON'T ALL COME INTO- AS
ANTICIPATED THAT THERE WOULD BE
SOME. DISCUSSION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE CONCERNING HOW
THOSE CUTS HAVE THOSE TRIGGERS
WHAT WHAT IS TRIGGERED AND WHAT
SHOULD BE FUNDED AS A RESULT O
THE TRIGGER. A BASED ON OUR
PRIORITIES THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL RATHER THAN JUST
DISCOVERING THAT THE TRIGGER
HAS STRINGS OF HAPPEN AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN. WE'RE WITH THE-
YOU GIVEN ANY. AT ALL THE
PROPS. TO BEING. IN TODAY WITH
CLOSE PRISONS. OF MOVING DJJ.
OF ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS AS
THEY BEEN ANY DISCUSSION ABOUT
THAT. YES AS YOU KNOW AND I AM
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND WE
WERE ALREADY ENVISIONED NAME
I'M CLOSING AT THE STATE PRISON
AND IT CERTAINLY IS A PRIORITY
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION- AS
WE'VE NOTED BEFORE THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY SOME AND- CONSTRAINTS
ON ACTUALLY IDENTIFYING. OF
THOSE PRISONS BUT CERTAINLY THE
ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO SET THOSE
CRITERIA SOME OF WHICH ARE
ACTUALLY SET INTO STATUTE- SO
THAT IS. SORT PUBLIC BACK RIGHT
HERE YEH THAT WE ARE TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION. I'M IT I'M
SORRY DID YOU I WAS QUESTION ON
A FUTURE DAY YEAH WHAT COMES
FIRST THE LIST FOR THE PRISON
TO BE CLOSED OR THE CAPITAL
OUT. RECOMMENDATIONS DO YOU
KNOW. I'M IT'S NOT A CERTAIN AT
THIS TIME WHEN WE WILL BE ABLE
TO PUBLICLY ANNOUNCED PLANS
YEAH OF THE WHICH PRISON WILL
BE CLOSED AND AS MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED THERE SOME EXCEPT
CONCERNS IN TERMS OF PUBLICLY I
MEAN I PERCENT OF BECAUSE OF
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
OFFICE IS ONE OF THE BIG
CONCERN SO I'M THERE'S SOME
UNCERTAINTY ON WHEN THE WHEN
THE TIMING OF THAT WOULD BE.
OKAY AS ANYONE ELSE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. YEAH I DON'T YEAH
THAT'S SOMETHING I DON'T THINK
I'M GONNA GET A LOT OF CHANCES
BUT GO AHEAD. AND MAYBE SOME
MOST OF THIS YOU MAY WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON I WHEN I GOT HERE
IN TWENTY TWELVE. I DO IT'S
LIKE ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. TO THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH. UNCOLLECTED FEES AND
FIND. AND I CAN REMEMBER
RECOMMENDING. GETTING SOMEONE
TO COLLECT THAT MONEY SOON
COULD GENERATE SOME REVENUE.
pEVEN SAYING SOMETHING AS A AS A
UNION GUY SAYING THINGS LIKE
MAYBE GIVEN IT TO A COLLECTION
AGENCY WE GET FIFTY CENTS ON
THE DOLLAR LISA GOT SOMETHING
BACK. AND I WAS PUSHED BACK
FROM THE DEPARTMENT THAT THEY
WOULD HANDLE IT SO CAN I GET UP
A REPORT ON. WHAT HAS HAPPENED
SINCE THEN BECAUSE AGAIN THAT'S
ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN FEES AND FINES THAT WE NEED
TO DO THAT TO. I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU CAN SAVE. ON PRISON
CLOSURES HOW YOU CAN PUT IN A
REPORT. THESE CHANGES GREAT SIX
POINT FOUR MILLION AND SAVINGS
AND 202-120-2020 TWENTY ONE.
AND HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. IN MORE IN FUTURE
SAVINGS IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
FACILITIES WERE TALKING ABOUT.
I REMEMBER BUILDING NEW POLICE
BASILIDES WITH HOLDING CELLS.
AND THEN WE MOVE STAFF AND WAS
A BIG ENOUGH BECAUSE IT TOOK
FIVE YEARS SOMETIMES TEN YEARS
TO BUILD IT. BUILDING COSTS
WENT UP AND IN THE SPIRIT WE
HAD FIVE YEARS AGO WE'RE
TOTALLY IRRELEVANT. ON FIVE
YEARS LATER AND- IT WAS A BIG
ENOUGH AND SO YOU REALLY DO
NEED TO KNOW THE FACILITY AND
WHERE ARE YOU GOING TO MOVE TO
PERSONNEL. I THINK EVEN BEFORE
YOU COME UP WITH A NUMBER SO
WILL BE REALLY HELPFUL. ON HOW
YOU. KIND OF FIGURED EVEN TO
SIX POINT FOUR IN SAVINGS WHAT
IS THAT BASED ON. AND A MOVING
FORWARD I WOULD EVEN LOVE TO
HELP YOU WITH. HOW TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MOVE PEOPLE FROM A
CLOSE FACILITY TO WE'RE GOING
TO BE STAFFING NEXT. IN
ADDITION. ON THE- ELIMINATING
DJJ AND. AND SOME OTHER THINGS
THAT WERE WE'RE DOING OUR
MOVING THINGS DOWN TO THE
COUNTY WE DID THAT BEFORE IT
WAS CALLED AB ONE OWN NINE WELL
WE JUST JUMPED EVERYONE BECAUSE
OF A FISCAL PROBLEM AND MORE
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE WERE UNDER
A FEDERAL MANDATE. WE JUST DID
IT WITH NO ACCOUNTABILITY WITH
NO PROCEDURES ON HOW THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHAT THEY GOT TO
THE COUNTY LEVEL. HOW THEY
WOULD NOT RECIDIVIST HOW WE NOT
BECOME A OUR FARM A DETRIMENT
BUT MOST IMPORTANT HOW THE
JAILS WOULD BE IMPACTED AND DO
WE GIVE THEM ENOUGH RESOURCES
FUNDING. SO THEY BECOME COULD
SUCCESSFUL WHEN THEY GOT THERE
AND SO EVEN THOUGH WE'RE TURN
ABOUT DJJ. AND SEEM TO THE
COUNTIES OF DO WE HAVE A FULL
PLAN TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
THE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
SUCCESSFUL. BUT AND THEN ON THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL. I'M LOOKING
AT A LIST OF CODED NINETEEN YES
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
WITHIN PRISONS THAT ARE THAT
NOTE THOSE NUMBERS ARE
INCREASING I THINK WE NEED TO
FULLY FUND AN OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL. BECAUSE WHEN
I ASK QUESTIONS OR SOMETHING I
DON'T UNDERSTAND ARE GOING ON
IN C. C. R. WE NEED INSPECTOR
GENERAL TO GIVE US. I'LL SAY
UNTAINTED BUT A THIRD PARTY
ASSESSMENT. OF HOW WE CAN- HOW
WHAT'S GOING ON BUT HOW WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD SO THAT WE DON'T.
SEND OUT THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS BACK OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY WE DON'T CONTINUE TO
INFECT PEOPLE THAT ARE WITHIN
THE FACILITIES WE PROTECT NOT
ONLY THE INMATES BUT MOST
IMPORTANT- THIS STAFF THAT'S
THERE- THE CORRECTION OFFICERS-
THE NURSES THE DOCTORS. ON THE
CLERICAL PEOPLE WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE SAFE ALSO WE
NEED TO PUT THAT EFFORT IN
THERE AND COME UP WITH. OF
THINGS THERE TO MAKE THAT THAT.
THAT INFECTION DOESN'T IMPACT
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS AS THEY GO BACK
AND FORTH OUT. OF THE PRISON
INSTANCE. I DON'T KNOW I DON'T
I DON'T KNOW I DON'T WANNA GO
ONE BY ONE. BUT I REALLY WANT
TO MAKE SURE- DOES QUESTIONS
GET ANSWERED SO I DON'T KNOW
IF. AGAIN LIKE DR WEBER SAID I
DON'T KNOW. IF WE HAVE TIME OR
SOMEONE WANTS TO. JUMP IN A
CHAIRED ITS BACON RIGHT NOW
AND- AND GIVE IT A SHOT OR-
YADA YADA SCREENSHOT SO I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU GUYS ARE SCRAMBLING.
OR OR WHAT IS THIS SOMETHING
YOU MAY WANT TO COME BACK TO
THIS COMMITTEE EITHER IN A
WRITTEN REPORT OR YOU WANT TO
COME BACK- US IN LA- WANTS TO
RESPOND OKAY. SO I DON'T KNOW
HOW WE GO FROM PLACE TO PLACE
WITH A HERE FRANKLY YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME NOW I CAN HEAR YOU YES
OKAY GREAT SO I JUST WANTED TO
RESPOND A BIT TO THE CONCERN
THAT IDENTIFYING THE PRISONS
FOR CLOSURE WOULD HARM-
RECRUITMENT FIRST OF ALL ONE
THING TO NOTE IS THAT GIVEN THE
UNFORTUNATE ECONOMIC- CLIMATE
THAT WERE IN IN HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT IT SEEMS LIKE
RECRUITMENT IS GOING TO BE
SUBSTANTIALLY EASIER THAN IT
WAS IN THE PAST. AND IT DID AND
I WANTED TO NOTE THAT IN YOU
KNOW RECENT ARTICLES- THAT
WE'VE LOOKED AT RELATED TO THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OF A PRISON
CLOSURE SOME- AS PRISON
EMPLOYEES ARE SAYING THAT THEY
WOULD PREFERRED THAT THE PRISON
SLATED FOR CLOSURE BE
IDENTIFIED BECAUSE RATHER THAN
WILD MINISTRATION BELIEVES THAT
IDENTIFYING THAT PRESENT WILL
MAKE YOU KNOW THE HUNDREDS OF
THEM PLEASE ADD A PRISON
NERVOUS WITHOUT IDENTIFYING IT
OR MAKE IT ALL THE EMPLOYEES
AND THE SYSTEM NERVOUS BECAUSE
NOBODY SURE. WHICH PRISON
CLOSED OR IF THEY COULD BE OUT
OF PRISON MEDLEY BE CLOSED ALSO
WITH RISK TO THE RECOMMENDATION
ON STICKY ADDRESS REGISTRY
FUNDING WAS BROUGHT UP ARE
BROKEN WAS TO FUND BUT TO JUST
TO TARGET THE INCREASED FUNDING
AT THE FACILITIES THAT ARE
HAVING DIFFICULTY RECRUITING SO
TIRED BREASTS WHICH WOULD
RESULT IN A MORE MODEST IN ON
ALSO HAVE TO RESPOND TO- ANY
OTHER POINTS THAT YOU WOULD.
LIKE ME TO RESPOND TO THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE COURSE. I OKAY.
SELECT MY QUESTION HAS TO DO
WITH HOW CD'S ARE IN THE
HOUSING BECAUSE BACK CONVICTED
AT THE BUT NOT YET. TO
EIGHTEEN. YES SERIOUSLY YEAH I
GUESS IT WOULD BE CITY SEE
OURSELVES. I'LL JUST AS ARE
SOME OF THE CONTENTS OF THAT.
FINANCE EVEN ANSWERED OR ARE
YOU L. L. YES. I'D BE SO- WERE
STILL REVIEWING THE TRAILER
BILL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THEY MAY BE ABLE TO
SPEAK TO OR THEIR PLAN BUT ONE
OF THE MODIFICATIONS THAT WE
WOULD RECOMMEND IS THAT STATUTE
BE CHANGED TO ALLOW. LOCAL
CORRECTIONAL A LOCAL YOUTH
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES TO
HOUSE THOSE YOUTH WHO HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED AS ADULTS BUT ARE- I
HAD BEFORE THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN-
IN ADDITION WE'D ALSO RECOMMEND
INCREASING THE JURISDICTION OF
THE JUVENILE COURTS TO TWENTY
FIVE TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
CASES IN WHICH THAT OCCURS.
OKAY OKAY AND THIS IS KIND OF
BEEN DISCUSSED ALREADY BUT I
HAVEN'T HEARD MUCH OF AN
ANSWER- AND MAYBE THERE IS NO
ANSWER BUT- IF SOMEONE OF
EVENTUALLY IS GOT TO ANSWER
THIS. AS WITH THE SHIP TO THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND THE
ELIMINATION OF DJJ. DO IS A
LEGISLATURE GIVE UP- OUR- OUR
COMPLAINT OVERSIGHT OF THE
TREATMENT REHABILITATION OF
THESE YOU. AND WE DO HAVE SOME
OVERSIGHT WHAT'S THE PROCESS
FOR ABOUT. THIS IS CRYSTAL SURE
THAT WOULD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I'M CERTAINLY NOT
AN EXPERT BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT
THE BOARD OF STATE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS I DOES CURRENTLY
AND PROVIDE SOME OVER OVERSIGHT
I'M IN THAT WOULD CONTINUE FOR
THESE YOUTH- THAT WOULD BE AND
I CAN I FACILITIES. HAVING
MISSED STONE ALSO RAISE THAT
ISSUE EARLIER. THAT WHICH WE
CANNOT GIVE UP OUR OVERSIGHT SO
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S SOME KIND OF REFLECTED
IN TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE OR
SOMETHING SO THAT. THE KIND OF
SERVICES OUR STUDENTS GET OUR
CARE KIDS GET IT NOT DEPENDENT
UPON WHAT COUNTY THEY LIVE IN.
YOU KNOW. GOOD TO HAVE SOME
HORRIBLE SITUATIONS IT'S A
WONDERFUL SITUATION SO WE HAVE
TO HAVE SOME CONSISTENCY. OF
THE RESOURCES IN THE SUPPORT IN
THE OUTCOMES THAT WE LIKE TO
SEE. YOUNG PEOPLE AS A RESULT
OF THAT ENGAGEMENT. SO I THINK
THE ISSUE OF US GIVING UP. OUR
OVERSIGHT COMPLETELY HAS BEEN
RAISED AND I THINK WE SHOULD
MAKE SURE THAT THAT. DOES NOT
HAPPEN. OKAY BUT ISSUE. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FOR NO ONE
ANSWERED ENDING A LINE TO LET
ME. PICK ONE HAS. THE TOPIC ONE
BABY DO DO YOU DO. BRING IT
OPPORTUNITY BRING IN REVENUE.
THIS IS SO TO ASK IN TWENTY
TWELVE EDIT I DON'T KNOW WHERE
WE ARE NOW. S. R. THIS IS I'M A
GENEROUS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I THINK- YOU KNOW I CAN
HAVE THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL SEND
YOU THE MOST RECENT COLLECTIONS
REPORT- IF THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL BUT- I THINK A LOT OF
THE UNCOLLECTED FINES AND FEES
ARE. ARE REALLY FROM YOU KNOW
PEOPLE WHO PROBABLY CAN'T
AFFORD TO PAY ANYWAYS- AND SO
THAT'S WHY THERE IS QUITE A
LARGE- I'M COLLECTED THAT
BALANCE BUT I THINK THAT'S- A
KIND OF SENSE OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF OUR ABILITY TO PAY PROPOSAL
THAT WE'VE INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET- BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
PROPOSAL WOULD WAIVE FINES AND
FEES FOR INDIVIDUALS BY AT
LEAST 50% IF NOT. I'M MORE OF A
BASED ON JUDICIAL DISCRETION I
THINK. YOU KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE UNIT AND
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL ARE
WORKING T TRYING TO HELP
PEOPLE SO THAT WAY WE CAN BE
ABLE TO COLLECT REVENUES- FROM
FINES AND FEES. I'VE BEEN I.
WANT TO SEE WHAT THEY PLAN IS
BECAUSE- IF YOUR PLAN IS TO
KEEP. IF YOU HAVE NO PLANS. BUT
I'VE EVEN HEARD FIFTY CENTS ON
THE DOLLAR I HAVEN'T HEARD AN
AMNESTY PROGRAM EVER HEARD
ANYTHING. FROM JUDICIAL COUNCIL
ABOUT HOW TO COLLECT IT OTHER
THAN THIS. THE SAME WOULD HAVE
BEEN DOING IT FOR THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS. AND WHAT MY POINT
IS. YOU CAN'T KEEP DOING THE
SAME THING OVER AND OVER AGAIN
EXPECT A DIFFERENT RESULT. WE
NEEDED THAT MONEY IN TWENTY
TWELVE. 271-516-1718 NINETEEN
TWENTY. EVER NEEDED IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO WHAT ARE WE DOING
ONE WEEK TO BE ABLE TO COLLECT
THAT AND MORE IMPORTANT IS
PROBABLY AN ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS JUST TO KEEP TRACK OF ALL
THAT. THAT COULD BE ANOTHER
STATE STATE WE COULD GET OFF
THE BOOKS SO I DON'T. I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THIS IS A KIND
OF A PRIORITY ESPECIALLY SINCE
IT WILL HELP. WITH ANY BUDGET
GAP THAT A FEW DISCOUNTS PASS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER AT
THIS IS- G. SORT OF WORK WITH
LA- AGAIN- I WOULD NOTE THAT
OUR OFFICE A FEW YEARS AGO DID
PUT OUT- SERIES OF REPORTS ON
STEPS THE STATE COULD TAKE TO
IMPROVE- THE COLLECTION A COURT
ORDER DEBT AND WE'D BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO ENSURE HAT YOU
AND THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- HAVE A COPY OF THIS
REPORT. THANK YOU DON'T KNOW IF
THEY IMPLEMENTED ANY YOUR IDEAS
I DON'T BELIEVE ARE I DON'T.
IDEAS WERE IMPLEMENTED NOW.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
BEFORE WE GO TO PUBLIC. OKAY IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE-
IN THE AUDIENCE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE WELL COMMENT. OKAY SEE NO
HANDS IN THE AUDIENCE OKAY THAT
MOVES US TO OUR OF REMOTE- THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS IT WILL BE
USING THE MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OUR CALL IN NUMBER IS.
ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
977-692-8957 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS. 283-438-2834 THREE EIGHT-
THAT CALL WILL BE IS ALSO
POSTED ON THE LIVE STREAMS-
LIVE STREAMS- SCREEN RIGHT NOW.
EACH PERSON WHO CALLS IN WILL
HAVE ONE MINUTE A PUBLIC
COMMENT WE WILL TRY TO STRICTLY
ENFORCE THIS BECAUSE IT CAN GET
RATHER LENGTHY GIVEN GIVEN THE-
ISSUES TRYING TO CONNECT AND IF
YOU'RE CALLING TO OPPSE OR
SUPPORT WAS DIFFERENT PROPOSAL
PLEASE STATE. WHAT SO WHAT
PROPOSAL YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
IN SPECIFICS IF YOU CAN ANSWER
ALL LET US KNOW IF YOU. ARE
OPPOSE IT THERE WILL BE TO MAKE
SURE WE GET IT ONE MINUTE. ANY
CALLERS ON THE LINE. SURE OKAY
WE HAVE ONE QUESTION FOR THE
MEMBER BUT- OKAY THE HIT. I
JUST WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE- THE
DISTANCE LEARNING- POST GRANT
PROGRAM IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
HAS BEEN ADDED TO THE BUDGET-
SPECIFICALLY- BECAUSE OF WHAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH NOW OR WAS
THAT ALREADY. IN PROCESS. THAT
THE FUNDING FOR THAT PROGRAM
WAS- FIRST PROVIDED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUT THE FUNDS
WEREN'T FULLY EXPENDED SO
THEY'RE GOING THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
RE APPROPRIATE THEM- SO WHEN
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED IT DIDN'T
HAVE COVERT NINETEEN IN MIND
BUT I WOULD DEFER TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AS TO WHETHER
THE- REASON THAT THEY'RE
PROPOSING A REAPPROPRIATION NOW
IS. IN LIGHT OF COVERED
NINETEEN. IS IT IS IT COULD
DEPARTMENT FINANCE SPEAK ON. TO
THAT QUESTION. THIS IS THE PART
OF FINANCE AND YES HE AMOUNT
THAT IS BEING RIVER LABOR TO
SIXTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION AS
WELL AS A TEN MILLION THAT'S
BEING RE APPROPRIATED. IS DUE
TO THE FACT THAT THOSE FUNDS
WERE NOT. ABLE TO BE ENCUMBERED.
BUT WAS THERE I DID IDEA THAT
WE ARE GOING TO GO TOWARDS
DISTANCE LEARNING BEFORE OR IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT
SPECIFICALLY BEING PROPOSED NOW.
THAT SPECIFICALLY BEING
PROPOSED ADAM AS A RESULT OF
THE CLUB IN NINETEEN. AND THE
ASSUMPTION THAT I'M AT LEAST
FOR THE NEAR TERM OKAY
INCREASING THIS DISTANCE
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES- IS
GONNA BE IMPORTANT. SO IMAGINE
THAT THIS IS A CHALLENGE THAT A
LOT OF DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND
PARTS OF THE GOVERNMENT ARE
DEALING WITH SO IS THERE- SOME
EFFORT TO COORDINATE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF DISTANCE
LEARNING TOOLS IN ORDER TO.
ACHIEVE GREATER EFFICIENCY.
UNFORTUNATELY WILL BE ABLE TO
SPEAK TO THAT QUESTION ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS. THANK YOU. I
WOULD NOT ONE OF THOSE THERE
ANYONE ON THE LINE. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE TO ENSURE OFFER A
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL GO TO THE
LINE OF LINE NINETY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
THE LINE OF LINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS PACKED AND I LIVE AND WORK
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF VIGILANT LOVE IN
LA COUNTY IN THE KNOW PVD
COALITION COMMAND THAT
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT BUDGET FOR
PVE. CAL ONLY AFTER CREATING
PAPER COMMUNITIES ARE ANY LIKE
PROGRAM IN THE COMING FISCAL
YEAR. HELLO YES IS CREATING
SAFER COMMUNITIES LIKE ITS
PREDECESSOR PROGRAM CALLED
PREVENTING VIOLENT EXTREMISM IS
AN ONGOING FEDERALLY FUNDED
PROGRAM FUNDED BY GRANTS FROM
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY. HELLO YES REQUESTED
TAKE FUNDING FOR ITS CREATING
FAVORITE COMMUNITY PROGRAM IN
JANUARY BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
UNDER THE AGENCIES CALIFORNIA
SPECIALIZED TRAINING INSTITUTE.
I'VE BEEN TO A LOT OF OUR WORK
FOCUSES ON THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN MENTAL HEALTH AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE WE UPHOLD THE
FRAMEWORK THAT PREVENTING
VIOLENT EXTREMISM AND CREATING
SLEEPER COMMUNITIES RELY
ALRIGHT BECAUSE THEY
CRIMINALIZE MENTAL HEALTH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR ONE
MINUTE COME IT YES. ONE ELSE ON
THE- YOUR NEXT WILL GO TO THE
LINE THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HEY TISHAWN COLLEAGUE FROM AND
POWER CHANGE AND NATIONAL MOST
FROM GRASSROOTS ADVOCACY
MOVEMENT BUT WE ARE ALL ON ALL
WE CANNOT HANDLE. I'M A
FOLLOWING UP ON A COMMENT FROM
THE YOUNG LOVE ABOUT CALLING TO
DEFINE ANY CALLOW YES PROGRAM
THAT CONNECTED TO THE COMING
ABOUT EXTREMISM FRAMEWORK-
WHICH WE KNOW WAS- HEATED
MCALARY AHEAD OF PVC PROGRAM
AND THAT RAN FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS AND THEN IN THIS PAST
JANUARY BUT IF THEY HAD A
PROPOSAL FOR THE CREATING IF
YOU'RE COMMUNITY- PROGRAM. FOR
CALLING ON THE SUB COMMITTEE TO
SCRUTINIZE THAT AND ACTUALLY-
ALL COURT A TRANSPARENT REPORT
FROM CAL YOU AS WELL- OUR CALLS
FOR QUALITY. WHAT KIND OF
INFORMATION BEING SHARED- JUST
AGAIN. REITERATING THAT ARE
CALLING ON THE. OKAY AND OUR
NEXT FROM FROM LINE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE MY
NAME IS ELLIE KEEP GETTING EL
AT THE AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE OF PEACE AND JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE U. S. WE OPPOSE ALSO
THE CREATING PAPER COMMUNITY
PROGRAM OR YOU YET MINUTES FOR
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALLOW YES.
LIKE A PILOT PROGRAM YOU CAN
EAT HE ACTUALLY IS AN ONGOING
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAMS BY
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY WORKING WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE FOR TEN YEARS SAME BASED
ON FAITH COMMUNITY THE JOB.
BEING GREEN. AND PERFECT FOR
THEM AND THEIR FAMILY. OKAY
THANK YOU BYE MUCH WE'RE TO OFF
TO STAY OF WHAT YOU'RE AND FAYE
OF A- TO NOT ACTUAL STATEMENT
OF PROGRAM SO THANK YOU. I
THINK THAT WAS IT- YES PROPOSAL
OKAY- ANY ANYONE ELSE YOU
ONLINE. UHHUH YES MA'AM ARE
DEADLINE LINE WON ALL FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TO DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CHEAP PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TODAY TO
EXPRESS OUR CONCERNS AS
CURRENTLY PROPOSED TO THEIR A
REALIGNMENT OF THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE TO. COUNTY
PROBATION I WOULD NOTE THAT AT
CURRENTLY DRAFTED AND I'VE
DISCUSSED HERE. THERE'S A
MYRIAD OF OPERATIONAL FISCAL.
CONSIDERATION BACK MUST BE
ADDRESSED WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF
THE SHARED POLICY GOAL TO SERVE
CALIFORNIA- YOU. UNDISTURBED WE
REPRESENT TO REFORM AND TALKED
ABOUT IT BUT. WITH TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES. IN A SUCCESSFULLY AND
ONE OTHER. BUT WE'RE HAVE DONE
SO WITH VERY CAREFUL PLANNING
ADDRESSING OF OPERATIONAL
IMPACT AND YOU WANT CABLE
PLANNING SOURCES TO SUPPORT
THOSE EFFORTS SO ARE YOU IN
FAVOR ARM ALWAYS TO THE
RECOMMENDATION. THAT'S WHAT WE
NEED TO KNOW ARE YOU IN FAVOR
OF IT ARE OPPOSED TO THE
RECOMMENDATION. WE HAVE
CONCERNS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
TALKING FURTHER WITH THIS
COMMITTE MINISTRATION. HOW TO
GET THERE BUT THE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE NEXT CALL. Q. R.
NECKLINE WILL BE LINE NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE WEBER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME WITH
THIS KIND OF STUFF- AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE CHILDREN BOB
FENNER CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE
THE THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
CHILDREN AND YOU CAN FOSTER
CARE COOLEY REPRESENT AND THE
FANS THAT SACRAMENTO IMPROPER
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
MAINTAIN CURRENT FUNDING LEVELS
FOR STATEWIDE DEPENDENCY
COUNSEL. WITH LIMITED ACCESS TO
THE COURTS A GIRL BACKLOG OF
CASES AND AN UNEXPECTED
INCREASE THE FOSTER CARE
POPULATION. ADVOCACY NEED TO
BRING IT CLIENTS ARE MORE
CRITICAL NOW THAN EVER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. ANYONE
I THANK YOU YEAH AND OUR NECK
YEAH NEXT ONE FROM THE LINE OF
ONE OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
STE. HELLO ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY
NAME IS MAXINE ISLAND AND I'M
WITH AND HOW IT CHANGE AND THE
NO PVN CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
CALLING ON THE STEP FIVE IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE TO OPPOSE
FUNDING FOR- YES THIS CREATING
SAFER COMMUNITIES PROGRAM-
WHICH CUENTA CON THAT LIKE THE
PRIMACY IN HATE CRIMES BUT IN
ACTUALITY LET. AROUND THAT
TARGET INTO ABOUT. REFUGEES THE
NEED OF COLOR AGAIN WORKS AND
MAYBE FIND WE PROGRAM. THANK
YOU AND WELCOME TO OUR NEXT
LINE LINE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTOR THAT SERVE THE
APPEAR OPPOSED TO THE PROPOSED
CUTS THE INTEGRATED SERVICE
CENTER NOT ONLY L. POLLY'S
PROGRAM AND THE CALL OUT
PATIENT CLINICS WE CAN FIND
THAT EMAIL TO THE COMMITTEE
WITH MORE DETAILS ON WHY. MUCH
THANK YOU. Q. AND OUR NEXT ONE
FROM THE LINE OF FLYING SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS MEET AS I'M A FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENT AND
FELLOW WITH THE RICHARD PEACE
PROGRAM WHAT THE TO EATING
BETTER PROGRAMMING WITH YOU THE
COLOR AND THOUGHT THE LATE.
TODAY I OPPOSE THE FUNDING OF
THE CREATING SAFER COMMUNITY
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY CAL A
WEEK AT. AND FUNDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
THANK YOU. ITS PILOT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU AND OUR NEXT LINE
FIND ONE TWO SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR THIRD CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THE BUDGET PROPOSAL PUT
FORWARD BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE TO BACK KILL THE LOCKS OF
FUNDING TO LEGAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS WE OPPOSE THE TRIGGER
REDUCTIONS AND THAT YOU DO HAVE
JUDICIAL COUNCILS ACCESS TO-
JUSTICE PROGRAMS THAT INCLUDE A
REDUCTION TO THE EQUAL ACCESS
FUND- FOR LEGAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS AND FINALLY- ON THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE REALIGNMENT
PROPOSAL. WE WANT TO SEE MORE
DETAIL BUT WE DO SUPPORT THE
MEASURE OF THE DJJ AGE
DISABILITIES THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND OUR NEXT
LINE ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
LINE IS OPEN. WE'LL GO TO OUR
NEXT LINE LINE SEVEN LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON. WORK ON BOARD ON THE
HAVE WON THE PUBLIC DEFENDER
YEAH SURE WE ASK FOR YOU TO
TAKE IN AND WILL YOU DOLLARS UP
FOR THE PUBLIC DEFENDER. LOCAL
BUT THERE'S AND THE GOVERNMENT
ABOUT GET OUT THE TICKET TO A
SMALLER. WE ALSO ASK ALL THE
FUNDING. PUBLIC UNDER THEM.
JEFF TOOK WE WANT IT TO. SPREAD
OF KOBE NIGHT ALL RIGHT THANK
MONEY THANK YOU THANK YOU YOU
MAY TO CONSIDER SENDING US AN
E. ALSO BE IT WAS DIFFICULT TO
HEAR YOU. EIGHT IN CLEARLY OKAY
THE NEXT CALLER. A LOT NEXT
CALLER LINE ONE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA AFTER WERE
ALSO- CALLING INTO OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF FUNDING FOR
PUBLIC DEFENDERS WE NEED TO
KEEP THAT ON THE BUDGET TO HELP
IN THE BEEN INDIGENT DEFENSE IN
SMALLER COUNTIES ANDWE ALSO
REQUESTED AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION. FULL PUBLIC
DEFENDER LAMENT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM PASSED Y THE
LEGISLATURE AS A CRUCIAL STEP.
DOCTOR READY COPING NINETEEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
AND OUR NEXT LINE IS LINED WITH
ONE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS STACEY
HEAT WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND ON BEHALF OF OUR THIRTY
SEVEN MEMBERS WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE HELLO YES FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL FOR THE
COMMUNITY ENERGY RESILIENCY
PROPOSAL- AND ON THE SAME NOTE
THAT WE WOULD SUGGEST REJECTING
A REQUIRED LOCAL COST SHARE FOR
THOSE FUNDS BECAUSE IT MAKES IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR UNDER
RESOURCE COMMUNITIES TO ACCESS
THAT MIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND OUR NEXT LINE
LINE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE MANAGER WEBER IS
NEEDED THANK YOU ARE TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFE DEJECTED.
LET YOU KNOW THAT WE ARE OPPOSE
THE TRIGGER CUT TO THE ADULT
RICHARD GRANT PROPOSAL WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO CLOSE
BJJ BLACK IF YOU MORE DETAILS
AS WELL. WE SUPPORT THE
RESTITUTION FUND BACK BILL BUT
HELP ME TO BE WHILE THE BABY BY
AT LAST THE ARTS POOL JUST
WANTED TO SHARE THAT WE ARE
DREAM A BILL AB TWO THREE FOUR
TWO. I JUST GOT OUT OF THE-
PARTNER WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION AS- WELL THE
MOST. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU. THANK AT OUR NEXT LINE FLY
FORTY CAROLINE IS. SH GOOD
AFTERNOON RENEE MENTOR WITH THE
CENTER JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GUY CUP
TOOK TO STANDARD DEJECTED IN
FAVOUR ACOSTA ALTERNATIVES
ENDING THE STATE INVESTMENT IN
THE FAILING SYSTEM ALLOWS US TO
BRING OUR FOCUS TO LOCAL-SYSTEMS FOR THE MAJORITY IF YOU
ARE ALREADY HELD. I ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER MODIFICATIONS TO
ENSURE THE SUCCESS OF THIS MOVE
AND THE SAFETY ISSUES ACROSS
THE STATE IN PARTICULAR IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE INVOLVED CBO
THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR FUNDING
THROUGH THE COUNTY GREEN
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF REGIONAL MODELS
GIVEN THEIR SIGNIFICANT ROLE
PROJECT. FOR JUSTICE IN BALK
YEARS THANK YOU WE WERE TALKING
GROUP LOCAL FACILITY THANKS
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND OUR
NEXT LINE LINE. ONE FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTER
MORNING WASHBURN ALL WITH THE-
AND YOU ALL INCOME JUSTICE. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
TO CLOSE THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE BECAUSE- HE JJ
SUBJECT. USE TO A CULTURE OF
FEAR AND VIOLENCE. IT'S
DISABILITIESARE FAR FROM HOME
AND PRISON LIKE. AND THEY LEAVE
YOU COMMA TIED IN AND PREPARED
FOR RELEASE. AND WE BELIEVE
THAT WE CANNOT SQUANDER THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING DJJ TO AN
END RIGHT NOW- VERY MUCH
CURRENTLY YOU CRIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
THE LINE OF ONE NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE
NINETEEN. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
LINE WILL BE LINE ONE FIVE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS TELLING HIM THAT I
DO AND WHAT THE WHAT IT MEANT
GROUP ON BEHALF OF NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA BEGIN A TRUMP
SUPPORTER OF THE GOVERNOR'S.
APPLE FOR FULL TO CLOSE DOWN
THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE WE BELIEVE BY CLICKING
THE FACILITIES WE CAN
TRANSITION TO ALTERNATIVE
MODELS THAT MORE CLOSELY
REFLECT OUR IDEAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND OUR
NEXT ONE LINE ONE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WADE ASK
YOU AND I'M AN ATTORNEY AT
LEGAL SERVICES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COMMENTING ON THE
TRAFFIC COURT ABILITY TO PAY
EXPANSION WE SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION WITH WITH CHANGES
THAT WE DETAILED IN A LETTER
PREVIOUSLY SUBMITTED TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. THE
IMPLEMENTATION ABILITY TO PAY
TEACHERS IN TRAFFIC COURT WHICH
SHE MEASURES RELIEF FOR OUR
CLIENTS BUT WE'VE ALSO SEEN
PROBLEMS WITH THE PROCESS. AND
LOTS OF INCONSISTENCIES ACROSS
COURTS IN CALIFORNIA THANK THE
PROPOSED EXPANDED EXPANSION
ADDRESS TO SOME BUT NOT ALL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE GO O
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE NASTIA LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER CDC ARE
PROP PATIENT CLINIC I PULLED
THE CLOSURE FOR OUTPATIENT
CLINIC DO NOT DIVERT OUR
PAROLEES WITH PERSISTENT
CHRONIC MENTAL ILLNESS WHO NEED
EXTRA ATTENTION ARE ALREADY
DISENFRANCHISED OVERWHELMED
MEDICAL PROVIDERS. HE TREATMENT
AND HOUSE AND STREAM LIKE YOU
VERY MUCH AS PART OF OUR
FORENSIC SPECIFIC TRAINING
THANK YOU. WE GO TO ONE. ZERO
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU THIS SANDY LEVIN AND YOU
GET AFTER OF LAW LIBRARY AND
THE PRESIDENT OF THE COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA COUNTY LAW LIBRARY
AND- I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSAL THAT WAS ADOPTED%
YESTERDAY. BY SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE TO INCLUDE
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN BACK
FULL FUNDING FOR COUNTY LAW
LIBRARY WHICH WOULD COVER THE
ESTIMATED LOSS IN FILING
FEATURE JUNE THIRTIETH OF THIS
YEAR. THANK YOU HAVE. A PATH IN
BEFORE I'M LOOKING. THANK WE'LL
GO NEXT TO LINE OF FIFTY THAT
FIVE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FIFTY ONE OF FIVE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE ONE WE DO WE HAVE
YOUR LINE OPEN YOU MAY HAVE
NEEDED YOUR PHONE. OKAY WE'LL
MOVE ON TO LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE LINE ONE
SIX ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
EE ARE NICE STRONGLY OPPOSE
EACH BJ CLOSER I'M A
PSYCHOLOGIST DJJ HAPPEN FOR
TWENTY YEARS. AND THE NEWS OF
THE DAY CLOSER HAS HAD A IMPACT
ON DJJ. THESE ARE KIDS WHO HAVE
FORTY FIVE YEARS LEFT IN DJJ
AND THEY'RE REALIZING THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO GO TO PRISON
TO CANCER THANK CALIFORNIA
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT US. AND THE
GROWING UP THE WAY VJ DAY KID
AND- HI WOULD YOU NOT JUST THE
KIDS HAVE MORE EIGHT IS A
THOMAS. IN THEIR LIFETIME IN
CHILDHOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CAROLINE
THANK YOU LINE ONE AND FOUR
LINE ONE FIVE FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DR
FLORENCE. ALAS I AM CALLING TO
OPPOSE THE CAT Q. THE CLINIC AS
WELL AS THE IS A GRAM OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE
ONE NUMBER EIGHTY TWO THAT'S
LINE EIGHT TO. FIND EIGHTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE EIGHTY TWO YOU MAY
HAVE YOUR PHONE MUTED WE DO
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU.
OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE
THAT BLIND ONE THREE NINE. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SHERRY ARE BEYOND A CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST AT DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE I'M OPPOSED TO
THE CLOSURE OF THE J. J.
SPECIFICALLY I WANT TO SPEAK IN
REGARDS TO THE FACT THAT HE
WOULD TREATMENT PROGRAM. MOST
OF YOU HAVE AG COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS AND IN THE COMMUNITY
AND FAILED. AND BEEN MANDATED
TO TREATMENT. BJJ MOST OF OUR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE DO NOT
RECEIVE A GREAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WHY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TEN THAT IS LINE ONE ONE ZERO.
FROM THE PACIFIC JUVENILE
DEFENDER CENTER WE SUPPORT THE
DJ GET CLOSURE PROPOSAL BUT
ONLY IF IT BUILDS AN IMMEDIATE.
ACTIONS TO PROTECT AGAINST
INCREASE TRANSFER TO ADULT
COURT WE AGREE WITH THE LA
SUGGESTIONS FOR CHANGES YOUR
SMALL STATUTES AND H. FOR LOCAL
CUSTODY WE ALSO AGREE WITH THE-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO SAID THAT
WE NEED TO MAINTAIN A STATE
LEVEL PRESENT. TO ENSURE THAT
THE NEW SYSTEM THAT ACCESSIBLE
AND FUNCTION PROPERLY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH USING GATE THAT YOU
AND YOUR STAFF TO COME IN UP
WITH BUDGET TRAILER LANGUAGE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOT A LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO LINE WANTED TO. YES HELLO
THIS TO START TRACING WHERE THE
BURKE CALLING ON BEHALF OF OPEN
PRIVACY WERE CALLING IN. TODAY
TO OPPOSE STATE FUNDING FOR
THEIR CREATING STAY FOR
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM WHICH CAN
BE FOUND IN THE JANUARY BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL FROM A WE ACT
THANK YOU FOR THE AGENCIES
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU ACOLYTES
TRAINING. THANK YOU WHY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO THAT
IS LINE ONE SIX TWO GO AHEAD.
YEAH THIS IS JIM ONE BURKE FROM
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA- WE
SUPPORT THE DJJ LOSURE
PROPOSAL ALONG WITH STATE
OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T REPLICATE THE SAME
RESPECT AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
THANK YOU. AND ON TO THE- THANK
YOU. WE HAVE ONE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY LINE ONE
SEVEN ZERO. HI YES THIS IS YET
NINE AND I AM CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL COMMUNITY
CENTER AND A CLINTON YAGO AS
WELL IF THE PALESTINIAN YOUTH
MOVEMENT. AND WE ARE CALLING
FIRST FOR AN AUDIT ON THE
ONGOING FEDERAL FUNDING FROM
DHS REGARDING ANYTHING RELATING
TO CREATING PAPER COMMUNITIES
AND PREVENTING BANK CHAIN OF
THEM AND WE'RE ALSO CALLING TO
SAY THAT WE OPPOSE FUNDING FOR
A WE AT THE END HELLO YEAH THIS
GRADING PAPERS COMMUNITIES AND
ANY LIKE PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. YEAH THANK YOU WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
LINE ONE ZERO ZERO. I AM
FRANKLIN ROBSON ON AND- I
OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION OF THE
PROHIBITION CLINICS THIS WILL
NEGATIVELY IMPACT OF RECIDIVISM
OUR JAILS ARE EMERGENCY ROOMS
AND ARE PSYCHIATRIC.
STABILIZATION UNITS PLEASE
CONSIDER IN KEEPING THE POLL
OUTPATIENT CLINIC THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
LINE A ONE EIGHT TWO EIGHT. I'M
HERE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
RELIGIOUS ACTION CENTER OF
REFORM JUDAISM REPRESENTING A
HUNDRED REFORM CONGREGATIONS
AND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY REFORM
JEWS DIRECT CALIFORNIAN
OPPOSITION. TO THE CDC ARE BUT
YOU'RE PROPOSAL AS USUAL RIVER
HEIGHTS VALUES THAT THE COURT
METRAGE THE PRIMACY OF SAVING A
LIFE AND WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE LIVES. AND
MONEY ARE PRISON THAT MANY
SERIOUSLY ILL AND ELDERLY
PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES ARE AT RISK
FROM COVERT NINETEEN THESE
PEOPLE ARE AMONG THE MOST
EXPENSIVE CARS ARE. LIKELY
BIRTH THE BUDGET YOU'RE OPPOSED
TO. THE CDC ARE BUDGET. INTENT
BUDGET INCREASE STATEMENTS CAN
BE. WE BELIEVE THAT INCREASE
SAVINGS CAN BE OBTAINED BY
RELEASING SERIOUSLY ILL- AND
ELDERLY PEOPLE IT DANGER FROM
KOBE NINETEEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR- LOW OKAY THANK
YOU IF WE HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR LINE
ONE EIGHT SEVEN FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEDICARE MEMBERS
GUARANTEE BOTH THE KICKERS
FOUNDATION REGARDING THE CALVET
PROGRAM AT A FIVE TWO TWO SEVEN
FOUR NINE SIX. WE OPPOSE- THE
DESCRIPTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
ENGAGING DIVERSION REVERSION OF
THE FUNDS THAT WE SUPPORT THE
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SEVEN LINE ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. HELLO MY NAME IS I MEAN
IT WAS ONE AND I'M WITH THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS HAVE THE KOBE AREA
OFFICE AND I AM CALLING TO MOVE
THE FUNDING FOR- YES IS
CREATING SEPARATE COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM AND WE'RE ALSO CALLING
FOR AN AUDIT GIVEN THE ONGOING
FEDERAL FUNDING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
FOR THIS PROGRAM. THANK YOU
THIS PROGRAM IS TARGETING
INTERVALLIC IMMIGRANTS LACKEY
PEOPLE TO USE THE COLOR THANK
pNUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
ONE LINE AT ONE EIGHT ONE. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS GREGORY
PUT OUT IN THE SHADE JUSTICE WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF CLOTHING DJJ-
THE EXPANDED PRISON CLOSURE AND
EXPANDING GOOD TIME CREDITS BUT
ONE NOTE THAT THOSE LAST TWO
ITEMS ON THE FLOOR NOT THE
FEELING. ESPECIALLY ON THE
CREDIT EXPANSION CAN BE DONE IN
A RETROACTIVE WAY IN A MUCH
MORE BROADER LAY WITHIN PCR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
WHY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY LINE ONE EIGHT ZERO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR- MY
NAME IS NOT CARRILLO POOR- AND
I'M PERPLEXED AT EVEN THOUGH
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED- CUTTING
THAT THE FUNDING FOR IT PRO
OUTPATIENT CLINIC TO ANY OLD
HAND ON THE HAD NOT MENTIONED
THIS TO YOU TODAY BUT IN ANY
EVENT. I'LL POST CLOSING THE
COLD OUTPATIENT CLINIC BECAUSE
THESE ARE THE FIRST LINE TO
STAND FOR THAT ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OUT OUT OF
PRISON. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY LINE ONE
IS THREE ZERO. AN ACCORD ON
BEHALF OF THE TECHNICAL PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE WE ASK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE RESTORE THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FUNDING FOR
INDIGENT DEFENSE AND FURTHER
ARGUMENT AUGMENT THE FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT COMMITTED AT THE
FORMS ARE ALSO STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE PROPOSED AT THE OP BUT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL. THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE LINE ONE EIGHT FIVE.
THE CHILDREN'S AND CALIFORNIA
WE SUPPORT DOJ CLOSURE WITH
STATE OVERSIGHT ENTIRELY TO
DHHS CENTER THE BCC PROTECTION
AGAINST. TO DEAL WITH THEM AND
USED IN THE EXISTING CHILD
WHERE FOR ACCOUNT. OKAY PROVIDE
GET. SURE TRANSITION THANK YOU
VERY. WE HAVE ONE NUMBER FIFTY
NINE THAT IS LINE FIVE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS AS LONG AS
I'M THE STATE POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR CUT FIFTY WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE TRIGGER CUTS WE SUPPORT THE
CLOSURE OF DJJ AND WE'RE
SUPPORTING AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY TWO ALONGSIDE HIS CHAIR
AND OTHERS WOULD LIKE TO BE A
RESOURCE IN HELPING TO REFORM
PAROLE THANK. BELIEVE THAT E
NEED A PLAN IN PLACE FOR
SITUATIONS LIKE THIS THAT'S WHY
WERE SUPPORTED WALDRON CITIES
ARE MERGING SEE PREP. THANK
SEPARATION QUOTE. WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
NINE LINE AT ONE EIGHT NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS A LIST
OF THE FACTS BUT IF SOMETHING
HAPPENED URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA I JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR THE COMMITTEE YOU
ISSUES WHERE WE EXPECT THAT
COUNTY COALITION LETTER IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME. AT THE FACT
THAT THE WORLD THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIAN
UCC HAVE WEIGHED IN ON THE DJJ
RELYING THAT AS WELL AS A
LETTER THAT WE SUBMITTED
COMMENTING ON THE ABILITY OF
PEOPLE BUT WE WERE JUST CHARGE
YOU TO CONFIGURE THE CALIPER
SPECTER. OR NEXT YEAR THANK YOU
THANK YOU. A WHY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN LINE. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN. REBECCA MARKETS
REPRESENTING BRADY UNITED
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE I ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE
AT THE DIFFERENT LAWCENTER
WE'RE GUARDING THE CALVET
PROGRAMS AND URGE YOU TO REJECT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WILL
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO RIVER
UNSPENT FUNDS DURING THESE
UNCERTAIN TIMES AND SUPPORT TO
CONTINUE AT THE CORPORATION OF
THE PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE ONE NUMBER NINETY
SIX THAT IS LINE NINE SIX. MY
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD THE
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO HE'S GOING
IN HI MY NAME IS BOB NANO THE
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE WITH ASIA
MARKAKIS I'M HERE ARE THE NO PD
EVEN CALIFORNIA COALITION. AND
I OPPOSE THE HELLO YES THANK
YOU FOR COMMUNITY PROGRAMS AND
ALSO CALL FOR AN AUDIT THANK
YOU FUNDING COMING FROM THE
CHEST THANK YOU FOR. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER SET SEVEN LINE.
SEVEN SEVEN. HELLO BOB AND
EARLY ON THE CLINICAL DIRECTOR
CALL THEY INTEGRATED THE
MENTALLY ILL PROBABLY
PROGRAMMING SACRAMENTO I'M
CALLING TO OPPOSED ELIMINATE
THE PROGRAM WE WILL SUBMIT A WE
HAVE COMMITTED OUR EMAIL-
DOCUMENTING ALL OUR REGION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY SIX LINE. ONE NINE SIX.
YES OOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ARE JUST THINKING
WE CAN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
I'M MORE CALLING TO OF COURSE
THE CLOSURE OF THE J. J. AND WE
DO SUPPORT THE LOCAL AND
REGIONAL RESPONSIBILITY. FOR
THE REHABILITATION OF YOUTH BUT
WE STRONGLY URGE THE
REALIGNMENT BE PHASED IN ORDER
TO AVOID AN IMMEDIATE AND
SUSTAINED SEARCH AND THE
TRANSFER VIEW FROM JUVENILE
COURT TO ADULT COURT. WHICH ONE
A CAR WITHOUT LOCAL
FUNCTIONALLY OF THE J. J. AND
SO WE JUST WANTED YOU TO KNOW
THAT KERN COUNTY FACILITIES ARE
DESIGNED TO HOLD YOU FOR SHORT
TERM AND ONLY THROUGH AGE
NINETEEN THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ADEQUATE INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR
THE D. DAY POPULATION THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A LINE NUMBER HUNDRED AND
FIFTY LINE ONE FIVE ZERO. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M DEANNA STILL A
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
I'M CALLING TO OPPOSE CLOSURE
OF THE CONTROL OUTPATIENT
CLINICS OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION WE SAVE
CALIFORNIA MONEY. THANK YOU. WE
ONE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND.
EIGHTY TWO NINE ONE EIGHT EIGHT
TWO. HELLO MY NAME IS REPEAL
GARCIA FROM PVC OUR OUR
LOCATION CLINIC OUR POPULATION
IS UNIQUE IN THE COUNTY
PROVIDERS ARE NOT PREPARED TO
ABSORB OUR CLIENTS AND TO
ADDRESS THEIR OWN SAFETY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE COPING POP
CLINIC. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE
LINE ONE NINE NINE. SO I'M
GOING TO LET YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
JUST THAT THE VENTURE YOUTH
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY AMADOR TO
YOU YOU WILL ONE THOUSAND ONLY
A PROPOSED UP. BOTH THE CLOSURE
DJJ OF THE COUNTY AND WHAT ARE
YOUR HANDS LOSE USE AND THE
STATE WILL NOT RECEIVE ANY
MONEY BUT SENT TO THE COUNTY
AND DID YOU SEE OUR THANK YOU.
THANK. YOU WE ONE HUNDRED AND
LINE TWO ZERO ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MIGHT GET DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WE
ASK THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REINSTATE
THAT TEN MILLION FOR THE
INDIGENT DEFENSE HIGHLIGHT
PROJECT AND THE ADDITIONAL TWO
POINT ONE MILLION COLLECT PT
AND ASKED THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER ADDITIONAL RESOURCE
THAT OUR PUBLIC DEFENDER SOCIAL
WORKER. WE OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF THE EXPANSION TO
THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL WE ASK THAT THE
STATEWIDE EXPANSION OF THE
ABILITY TO PAY PILOT PROGRAM
THE STRENGTH AND WE'RE OPPOSED
TO THAT PROPOSED PPL
ELIMINATION OF REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE EXISTING
DATA IS INADEQUATE TO DETERMINE
WHICH ASPECTS OF THE PILOT
PROJECT ARE EFFECTIVE AND
LEGISLATIVE OVER THANK. YOU CAN
YOU KNOW WE ALSO ASKED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION- THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR CUT THE BST FEE
FOR THE ADULT REENTRY GRANT.
PROGRAM THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU. WE HAVE ONE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED IN FORT LINE. TWO ZERO
FOUR. HI MY NAME OF HOW MY
REVIEWS OF THE ANIMAL CHANNEL
THE PARTNERSHIP FOR THE DEAF
AND THE AMERICAN. PAN WITNESS
HARM OF THE TRACKING OF LOCAL
COMMUNITY BY PROGRAMS SUCH AS
THE V. E. P. P. AND THE CURRENT
ITERATION CREATING. A COMMUNITY
PROGRAM WE OPPOSE FUNDING FOR
THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE THEY LEAD
TO THE VERSION OF. TRUST
BETWEEN ORGANIZATION AND THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE
TWO HUNDRED AND FIVE LINE TWO
ZERO FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS KYLE MODEL ASK US DEAL WITH
COMMUNITY WORKS- WE HAVE THREE
ITEMS WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
PROPOSED TRIGGER REDUCTION TO
THE ADULT RANCHER GRANT THIRTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE WERE VERSION
PROPOSED- VERSION OF THE FUNDS
FOR CALVET. YG AND TRIBAL
DIVERSION FUNDS AND WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE DJJ
REALIGNMENT WITH OVERSIGHT- IT
IS NONSENSICAL TO IN THE SAME
BREATH CUT DIVERSION FUNDING
CUT REENTRY FUNDS WHILE ALSO
RELEASING PEOPLE AND STOPPING
YOUTH PRISONS. THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVEN LINE. TWO ZERO SEVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOING BACK A
FELLOW BAKER SAID OF REALLY
RIGHT FOR POSITIONS IN LESS
THAN SIXTY SECONDS. WE SUPPORT
THE REALIGNMENT OF DJJ USED TO
CARRY SUPERVISION WE SUPPORT
THE CLOSURE OF I DON'T KNOW
WHAT HE'S- WE SUPPORT THE CAP
ON PAROLE FOR TWO YEARS FOR
MOST OFFENERS. AND WE SUPPORT
GREATER CREDIT EARNING
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN CDC ARE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE
ONE TWO HUNDRED AND ELEVEN LINE
TWO ONE ONE. TIM ROBBINS YEAH
SCARING THE RECORDER DIRECTOR
OF OPERATIONS FOR THE PRISON
CULTURE CAPITAL HAS. AND MADAM
CHAIR WE WANT YOU OPPOSED TO
CUT- THE TRIGGER CUT THE BSB BE
ADULTERY AND REPROGRAM-
ESPECIALLY AT THIS TIME- WHEN
HE- CDC ARE HAS SPECIFICALLY
REACH OUT YOU- THE BST T. TO
ASSIST WITH IN- RELEASE OF THE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY- THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT- RETURNED FROM
KOBE- THE EARLY COVERED
RELEASE. REMOTE CONTROL PROGRAM
ISA LIFELINE. TO THE PEOPLE
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN LINE SIX
SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS MAGALY
HAGANAH BEFORE. HE NOW BE A- OR
COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAM FOUND BY
YEAH STUDY AND WE ARE NEXT
POINT TRANSITION. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
LINE AT ONE ONE FIVE. A LINE
ONE ONE RIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HELLO. HELLO. HELLO. GO AHEAD.
OKAY LINE ONE ONE FIVE A PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
ROLAND AGO MADE AYE OPPOSED THE
CLOSURE OF PAROLE OUTPATIENT
CLINIC AND AT MY POSITION THANK
YOU. POINT NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTEEN THAT IS LINE TWO
ONE EIGHT. MORE YEAH IT WOULD
BE A LIE FOR THE MEDICAL ALL
BLANK WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
CLOSE THE DAY BEGAN WITH MINOR
MODIFICATION INCLUDING A BALL
THE FIFTY OPEN OUR PROCESS FOR
DEVELOPING REGIONAL MODELS.
WILL LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AGE TO
TWENTY ONE THAT RESULTS AWKWARD
TRANSFER THIS WE HAVE TO PAY TO
MAINTAIN FIFTEEN MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR THE YOUTH GRANT
THAT THE THOUGHT AND PROBABLY
YOU BACK WORKING GRANT PROGRAM
IF YOU THOUGHT OF HARMFUL AND
EFFECTIVE COST YOU'VE WRITTEN.
A LOT. YOUR ONE NOT OKAY I KNOW.
AT TWO AND TEN IS ALL LINE ONE.
IT'S NOT THE LACKEY WITH MAC.
BY THE PUBLIC AFFAIRS THE
PEOPLE GAUGE MEANT PART OF THE
NOTE IN CALIFORNIA ELECTIONS
AND OTHER NATIVE SAN DIEGO AND
LET IT AND WANT TO WALK
MILITARIZED BORDER WEEKEND OUR
COMMUNITY KNOW THE IMPACT OF
DECEPTIVE PROGRAMS MUCH LIKE
PVA BUT TO BE FRANK I WANT TO
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO HEAR
STORIES OF PAIN AND NOT FIND.
THE DECEPTIVELY NAMED GRADING
PAPER COMMUNITY PROGRAM HELLO
YES- SO I'M ALSO CALLING FOR
AND I DID GET AN ONGOING
FEDERAL FUNDING FROM THE G. A.
B. A. CAT AND MOST DEFINITELY
DID PROGRAM AND LIKE OTHER PVP
PROGRAMS ARE NOT KEEPING OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. AND I
COMMUNITIES. THAT THAT PART
ENOUGH. THANK YOU. IF MY NAME.
LINE EIGHTY TWO EACH TO. PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE EIGHTY TWO.
EIGHTY TWO WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU. WILL MOVE ON TO
MY NUMBER TWENTY THAT FLYING
TWO ZERO. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I'LL
KEEP MINE QUICK MANY CAMILLE
ROWE IN THE SOCIAL WORKER WAS
BROUGHT PATIENT CLINIC OUTLOOK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MISTER JONES
SAWYER THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU
PUT POLITICALLY TODAY WHEN YOU
SAID THAT AB ONE ON NINE
ESSENTIALLY DUMPED ON THE
COUNTY THAT OUT ACCOUNTABILITY
WITHOUT CARE HOW THEY WOULD BE
IMPACTED. ELIMINATING THE PEEL
BUT PEOPLE AROUND THEM ARE YOU
LABOR OVER HOMESTEAD. I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE
ELIMINATION OF THE PROHIBITION
CLINIC OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. YEAH WHY NUMBER
FORTY NINE THAT IS A LINE FOR
NINE. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
HELLO. YES HI BUT THE CATALINA
MARTIN FROM OFFICE CENTRAL LIKE
AS A LOT ABOUT THAT I AM THE-
DIRECTOR OF THE PROGRAMS IN
APATHY WE'RE LOCATED IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA WE'RE CALLING TO
OPPOSE HELLO YES. UNITIES
PROGRAM WE BELIEVE THAT NO
MARRIAGE- AND WE ARE ASKING
THAT. YOU ADVOCATE FOR THE
RETURN OF TEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO INDIGENT DEFENSE. AND WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE BUDGET TO SAVE
LIVES BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN
DIVESTING AND CRIMINALIZATION
INCARCERATIONS AND INVESTING IN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND ALTERNATIVE THANK ARCHERY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CAN LINE
IT TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
LINE TO. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DAVID HOW THE LOCAL WITH
INDICATE THAT THE FACT IS ECHO
MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS
REGARDING SUPPORTING THE
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT AND ALSO
EXPANDING THAT CONDIT CREDIT
FOR PEOPLE INCARCERATED IN
SEPARATELY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE HAVE LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX LINE ONE FOUR SIX. HI
MY NAME IS SERRA GIVE THEM A
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE CLOSURE TO
THE PRO OUTPATIENT CLINICS AND
THE IS NOT PROGRAM. YEAH THANK
YOU. WE HAVE ONE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE LINE TWO
THREE ONE. HI MY NAME IS JUSTIN
WEBER I'M A SOCIAL WORKER OF
PROHIBITION CLINIC I THIS IS
HOLLY OPPOSED THE CLOSER THE
PSE CLINICS ITS MAPS PROGRAM WE
ARE NOT A DUPLICATION OF
SERVICES. WE PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT AND ONGOING RISK
ASSESSMENT TO OUR COMMUNITY
THANK YOU PROVIDING CARE FOR
THOSE MOST IN NEED AND
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY LINE TWO
THREE ZERO. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR DENNIS AS WELL WITH
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA- IN
OPPOSITION OF ANY ONGOING
FUNDING TO CAL YES REGARDING
THAT CREATING FACTOR
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. THE OF
MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO LINE TO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MY NAME
IS DOCTOR MCGREGOR I AM A
SENIOR PSYCHOLOGIST SPECIALIST.
AND AYE OPPOSED TO
RECOMMENDATIONS TO CUT YOU'LL
SEE AND IS MAP. MAPS JOB IS TO
ASSESS ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THE
MOST SEVERE MENTALLY ILL.
EARLIER IN THE STATE WHICH IS
ABOUT FOR THE FIVE HUNDRED
PROBABLY IS AT ONE TIME THANK
YOU CLOSE IN THIS PROGRAM WILL
HAVE IT FIRST A FIX. ON IS MAP
CLIENTS AND THE COMMUNITY AT
COMMUNITY AT LARGE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. A LINE A ONE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY SIX LINE AT ONE EIGHT
SIX SIX. HI BUT REALISTICALLY
THERE WITH THE AMERICAN AND
SERVICE COMMITTEE AND ON THE
ORGANIZATION OF CALIFORNIANS
UNITED KERR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET
I'M CALLING TO STRONGLY I SHOW
MY SUPPORT FOR PLAN TO CAUSE
DJJ AS WELL AS PLANS TO CLOSE
TO STATE PRISON THIS IS THE
BARE MINIMUM OF WHAT WE NEED TO
DO RIGHT NOW. I ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BUDGET TO SAVE
LIVES AND BELIEVE WE NEED TO
INVESTING COMMUNITIES NOT CAGES.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE LINE
TWO THREE THREE. HELLO MY NAME
IS LINDA ALLEN STEWART I'M A
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
WITH THE PAROLE OUTPATIENT
CLINIC PROGRAM I STRONGLY A
FLOW OPPOSED THE ELIMINATION OF
THE PROGRAM. WE PROVIDE NOT
ONLY MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
FOR SUBSTANCE ABUSE AS WELL AS
RISK ASSESSMENT TO THE
COMMUNITY WERE READILY
AVAILABLE A PAROLE THE CAN BE
SEEN THE DAY THEY GET OUT AND
AT EVERY DAY DURING THE WEEK
THAT THE AGENT OR THE PAROLE WE
WANT TO BE SEEN THANK YOU VERY
A LOT OF PEOPLE TAKE ENOUGH
COUNTY SERVICES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
SIXTY EIGHT THAT IS LINE SIX
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS LOUISE GIVE ME NO I AM
A CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF COAL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE- THE CLOSING OF
THE PROHIBITION CLINIC WE ARE
THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE FOR A
CLIENT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IT
JUST AS A REMINDER IF YOU WOULD
STILL LIKE TO GET INTO THE
QUEUE IF YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY
DONE SO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO TO GET INTO THE QUEUE
AGAIN THAT IS ONE. THEN IT ZERO
WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT. LINE
TWO THREE EIGHT IS NEXT. HELLO
MY NAME IS NATASHA HUEY AND A
MEMBER OF STORAGE AREA WHICH IS
A MEMBER OF CALIFORNIANS UNITED
FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET. AND WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO CLOSE THE DJJ AND AT LEAST
TO PRISON. IT SUPPORT THE LA
OWNS RECOMMENDATION TO CLOSE
FIVE PRISONS AS WELL AS HELP ON
PRISON INFRASTRUCTURE WE OPPOSE
CUTS TO THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE AND ANY FURTHER
INVESTMENT IN PROBATION
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY NINE LINE ONE FIVE
NINE. HELLO JESSICA PARKER WITH
THE WESTERN PLAN ARE ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE'D LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH REGARD TO THE
ABILITY TO PAY PILOT BUT THOSE
MADE BY ACLU ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH REGARD TO THE CLOSURE OF
D. J. J. AND PRESENTS WITH
THOSE MADE BY THE BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR NETWORK. AND ALSO- AND
WITH REGARDS TO THE RE ENTRY
AND- SERVICES AND ANTI
RECIDIVISM SERVICES THAT WE
WOULD OPPOSE THOSE AS WELL AND
JUST POINT TO THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT IN ORDER BY MAKING SURE
PEOPLE HAVE IDENTITY. AND
ACCESS AND BASIC NEEDS LIKE HOW
FRESH CAL WORKS AND WILL
COMPLAIN IN. TRAINING PROGRAMS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE
HAVE NEXT LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TWO LINE TWO FIVE TWO.
HELLO THIS IS NATASHA MINSKER
ON BEHALF OF MARK JUST TO
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT CLOSING
DJJ INTO PRISON WE SUPPORT THE
PAROLE REFORM PROPOSAL AND THE
EXPANSION OF CREDIT. WE ASK
THAT YOU RESTORE FUNDING FOR
THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL WE ASK THAT YOU RESTORE
FUNDING FOR INDIGENT DEFENSE
ACCORDING TO THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY PROPOSAL AND TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR INDIGENT
DEFENSE TO IMPLEMENT REFORMS
PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU. GIVE MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE LINE TWO
FOUR NINE GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS CAMILLE COMMUTE JUST A
COALITION WE URGE THE ADOPTION
OF THE BUDGET TO SAVE LIVES AND
PUT PEOPLE OVER PRISON PROFIT.
IN ADDITION WE COMPORT THE
CLOSING OF BJJ WITHOUT
INCREASING TRANSFERRED INTO
ADULT PRISONS AND ALSO COULD BE
CREATION OF COMMUNITY PLANNING%
PRACTICES REGARDING WHAT WOULD
BE BUILT AT THE COUNTY OF AN
ALTERNATIVE. FINALLY DO TO.
SUPPORT THE BUDGET NOW FOR THE
OFFICE GENERAL. AND TO ACT AT
THE INSPECTORS DO A FULL- AUDIT
OF THE FORCE MURDERS OF THE
YARD AND IF IN FACT CALL THE
NINETEEN ON PCR SYSTEM THANK
THANK YOU. AND MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE LINE TWO
FIVE FIVE. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS VICTORIA
ELECTED WITH THE LAWYERS
COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS OF
THE CAMP AND GOBAY AREA
REGARDING EXPANSION OF THE
ABILITY TO PAY CONTACTED LIKE
TO POINT YOU TO THE MALL
AMENDMENTS IN A LETTER FROM A
LAWYER COMMITTEE THE ACLU THE
WESTERN CENTER AND THE BEAUFORT
BECAUSE OF MY CALIFORNIA TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE DATED MAY
EIGHTEENTH. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR THAT IS
LINE TWO FIVE FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS JOHN
CONSULTANT ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO VOICE
OUR CONCERN IN OPPOSITION WITH
THE WHOLE WORLD FORM PIECE
WHICH CAPS PAROLE FOR THOSE
CONVICTED OF MURDER MAYHEM. A
GREAT BODILY INJURY ROBBERY
ATTEMPTED MURDER ARSON EXPLODE
IN A DEVICE THAT KILLED SOMEONE
KIDNAPPING AND ASSAULT WITH
INTENT TO COMMIT A FELONY MY
WAS PHONE. YOUR WE'RE NOT THE-
THANK YOU. YEAH MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX LINE TWO
FIVE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DIMITRIUS PONDERED AND
I'M A CLINICIAN A SOCIAL WORKER
WITH THE PAUL OUTPATIENT CLINIC
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY I WANNA
HOLD THE CUT TO THE PRO
OUTPATIENT CLINIC AND TT ARE WE
WORK WITH THE CHRONICALLY
MENTALLY ILL ACTUALLY ILL. OR
RENT THE POPULATION WE REALLY
THINK THAT MOST OTHER QUESTION
YOU HAVE DIFFERENT COMMUNITY
POPULATIONS ARE NOT ACCUSTOMED
TO WELL I DEFINITELY WANT TO UP
HOLD. THANK YOU FREE SHE'D. IN
WE HAVE MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SEVEN LINE. TWO
THREE SEVEN. HELLO THIS OF
MARTHA MOXLEY LCSW I WORK IN
THE IRVINE GIRL OUTPATIENT
CLINIC AND IRVINE FOR MANY
YEARS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THE CLOSER OUR CAT OF THE HR WE
PROVIDE A UNIQUE SERVICE THAT
IS NOT A DUPLICATION OF
SERVICES AND WE DEFINITELY
HELP. CARLY'S RE INTEGRATE THAT
PROMOTE PUBLIC SAFETY AND WE
DEFINITELY SAVE THE STATE MONEY
IN THE LONG RUN THANK YOU WITH.
BLACK. ARTERIES AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE THAT IS LINE
TWO TWO FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS REALLY A SHARP
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TROUBLE FAMILY
COALITION ON BEHALF OF OUR
THIRTY FOR NUMBER CHIMES WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE TRIGGER
CUTS TO THE TRAVEL YOUTH
DIVERSION GRANT FUNDING
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. WE HAVE MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE THAT IS LINE TWO TWO NINE.
WHAT'S MORE STERN TRIBAL
ATTORNEY FOR THE CHAIR MORE
UNION TRIBE OF SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY CHICKEN RANCH RANCHERIA
TOLD ME COUNTY AND THERE IS A
GETTING RANCHERIA WE SUPPORT
CONTINUED FUNDING FOR THE
TROUBLE YOU DIVERGING GRANT
PROGRAM FOR TWO REASONS ONE
STATISTICS SHOW. THAT THE
PROGRAM WORKS AND TO IN A LONG
GREEN IT'S GOING TO SAVE
CALIFORNIA MONEY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN THAT IS LINE ONE ONE
EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS PLAYING A
RESIDENT OF CLOTHES CALIFORNIA
AND I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
OPPOSITION TO PLUG IN THE POLL
OUTPATIENT CLINICS AS I KNOW
HOW CLOSELY THEY WORK WITH THE
COLLECTION. AND OUT NOT ONLY
MAINTAIN THEIR CALL VOLUME
SERVICES ARE NOT. AVAILABLE IN
THE COUNTY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN THAT IS LINE TWO ONE
FOUR. HI MY VIKTOR PETRENKO I'M
A PSYCHOLOGIST THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL FACILITY A PRISON IN
BACK OF BILL THAT I'M OPPOSED
TO CLOSING THE JJ AND PLC THESE
ARE POPULATION WILL NOT GET
SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE FOUR
LINE NUMBER ONE SEVEN SIX LINE
ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR I AM
CHAIRMAN RAYMOND C. HITCHCOCK A
WORLD RANCHERIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBE. NINETY WITH BUDGET CUTS
TRIBAL YOUTH VERSION GRANT
PROGRAM ALLOCATED WE STRONGLY
URGE LEGISLATURE TO LEAVE THIS
IN NATIVE YOUTH ARE TOP OF
BATTERY STAGGERING STATISTICS
AS TRIBAL LEADERS WE WANT TO
CHANGE THIS PARADIGM THIS
PROGRAM ALLOWS TRIBES TO HAVE A
HANDS ON TRADITIONAL AND
CULTURAL APPROACH THAT'S
ALREADY PROVEN TO BE SUCCESSFUL
FOR OUR AT RISK TRAVEL YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. AT MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO THAT IS LINE TWO
THREE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
DOCTOR CRITICAL WALK FROM MY
WORK AT THE DEPARTMENT OF. NOW
THEY AFFECT- THE YOUTH THAT WE
SERVE FREQUENTLY HAVE FEEL AS
THOUGH THEY FAILED MULTIPLE
COUNTY PROGRAM WHICH CAUSES
THEM TO HAVE A HARDER TIME
TRYING. FREQUENTLY I WORK WITH
YOU CAN FEEL THAT WE ARE THE
ONLY AGENCY HOOK OR CROOK
BERMAN THE ONLY AGENCIES WITH
PROVIDED CONSISTENT CARE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IN ADDITION. WE
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE. THANK YOU
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY SEVEN THAT IS LINE
TWO FOUR SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS
FRANCESCA ARE LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER AT THE ROLL UP
YOU SHOULD CLINIC. THAT TO CDC
ARE AND I'M GOING TO STRONGLY
OPPOSED THE BUDGET BECAUSE OF
THE P. O. C. AND IT'S NOT A
GRAM THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE
HAVE ONE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THAT IS LINE TWO SIX ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
BROUGHT YOU DOLLY I'M A
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER. ALL TO
UP WITH MY OPPOSITION TO THE
CULTURE THE FULL OUTPATIENT
CLINICS THANK. WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN THAT IS LINE
FOR SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
DOCTOR USED TO I'M OF THE
CULTURE WORKING WITH THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
AND I'M STRONG OPPOSITION OF
FEATURES A CULTURE THANK YOU
YEAH. THANK YOU. WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SIX LINE TWO SIX SIX. HI MY
NAME IS JENNIFER SO YOU KNOW
I'M A CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
WITH PO THREE I WAS CALLING
BECAUSE I NEEDED OPPOSED TO
ELIMINATION OF HIS FEAR GAUGE
ARE- WE OFFER TEAM WITHIN ON BY
THIS INCIDENT CONTAINING AT.
LEAST MEDICAL CARE DENTAL CARE
EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT
REINTEGRATION INTO COMPUTER
GAMES THANK YOU VERY. WE HAVE
ONE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY LINE TWO SEVEN ZERO.
AFTER. I PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
TWO SEVEN ZERO. AB TWO SEVEN
ZERO YOU MIGHT HAVE YOUR PHONE
NEEDED WE DO HAVE THE LINE OPEN
FOR YOU. I BYE BYE. ONE TWO
LINE NUMBER TWO FIVE EIGHT ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. LINE TWO FIVE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS NATALIE O'BRIEN I AM
THE SOCIAL WORKER FOR SAN LUIS
OBISPO FOR ALL AND I OPPOSE A
CLOSING APPEAL SEE BECAUSE WE
ARE NEEDED AND ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WE KEEP THEM SAFE
THANK THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YEAH WHY NOT TWO HUNDRED AND.
FORTY EIGHT NINE TWO FOUR
EIGHT. PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY. AGAIN ONE
TWO FOUR EIGHT WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU. HI MY NAME IS
CURE TO MASON I'M A CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST AT DJJ AND I AM IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF THE
CLOSURE DJJ THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. IF THERE IS ANYONE ELSE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO GET INTO THE
QUEUE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
BE IN THE QUEUE PRESS ONE AND
THEN IT IS ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE NUMBER. EIGHTY TWO LINE
EIGHT TWO ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE EIGHTY TWO.
ONE EIGHTY TO THE LINE IS OPEN
FOR YOU. EIGHTY TWO IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK THE LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. FOR THE.
PINE EIGHTY FIVE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. LINE EIGHTY FIVE THE
LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS TRACY
WHITE SEIU ONE THOUSAND I'M A
STEWART AT DJJ AND I STRONGLY.
OPPOSE THE CLOSING OUT DJJ
ALONG WITH MY FELLOW TEACHERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE HAVE
ONE TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. LIKE TO
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
I'M YOU'LL TRY I COLLEGES THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS AND I'M APPEALING TO
BE OPERABLE LEGISLATORS TO
PLEASE NOT CLOSE BJJ THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE WHY
NUMBER ONE FOUR ZERO ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ONE FOUR YEAR OLD THE
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
HELLO MY NAME IS DR FAHLMAN ON
A COLLEGE DEGREE K. J. AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED THE CLOSING
THE TAKE. AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER ONE ONE SIX AGAIN THAT
IS LINE ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN.
HI AMY- DLI CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKER AT THE BOTTOM LINE
PROFIT AND APOLLO'S.
ELIMINATION APPEALS IT BECAUSE
WE ARE THE FIRST LINE OF THE
BANKING YOU PROVIDE THAT
THEY'RE BACK TO CARE AND OUR
SERVICE. PEOPLE TO FOR LEASE
THANK A BETTER VITAL WE SPEAK.
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
NEXT WE HAVE ONE NUMBER TO
HUNDRED AND NINE THAT A PLANE
TO SIX NINE PLEASE AHEAD. MY
NAME IS KEVIN CAMERON I'M A
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER IN
SACRAMENTO WITH THE POOL ALL
OUTPATIENT CLINIC AND I JUST
WANT TO VOICE MY OPPOSITION TO
CLOSING THE PLC. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE LINE
TWO SIX THREE. HI MY NAME. WHAT
COLLEGES GET BJJ AND I'D SAY
YOU'VE GOT TO COULD BE PICKED A
OPEN WE PROVIDE CRITICAL
SERVICES THAT CAN BE PROVIDED
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL AND YOU ARE
BEING REHABILITATED WE NEED TO
KEEP OUR COMMUNITY SAFE THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU TO TELL THEM
WHAT. THANK YOU WE HAVE MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FOUR LINE TWO TWO FOUR. WELL MY
NAME IS THE NET CABRIO-
PHARMACISTS THIRTY THEIR DAY
UNLIKE EXPRESS MY STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE CLOSURE OF
THE DJ. THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NINE LINE TWO FIVE NINE. THANK
YOU FIFTY NINE WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU. PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE TWO FIVE NINE. OKAY WILL
GO NEXT TO LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR LINE TWO SEVEN
FOUR. TWO SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS AMY
CAN I'M A CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKER WITH PAROLE OUTPATIENT
LOS ANGELES CUTTING POLL
OCCASION CLINIC WILL DUMP THE
VIOLENT INMATES THAT WE TREAT
THAT COULD NOT BE REALIGNED
UNDER AB ONE ONLINE ON TO THE
COUNTY. THANK YOU CLOSE THANK
YOU. WHY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR LINE TWO FOUR FOUR.
A LINE TO FOUR FOUR WE HAVE THE
LINE OPEN FOR YOU. THIS IS
DOCTOR CREEK COUNTER PROGRAM
COORDINATOR A SEX OFFENDER
PROGRAM AT DJJ WORKING WITH YOU
MOST OF WHOM HAVE ALREADY
FAILED OUT OF COUNTY PROGRAM WE
OPPOSE THE CLOSURE OF DJJ.
THANK YOU. NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO LINE ONE THREE
TWO. AFTER AGING AND WORK WITH
DJJ I'M A LICENSED CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST AND I OPPOSE THE
CLOSURE OF THE DJJ. WE HAVE MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
ONE LINE TO SEVEN ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS MY
THOUGHTS ON DOCTOR PETERSON A
STEP BY CRISIS FOR THE PROBLEM
PRO BALL. THEM OPPOSING THE
ELIMINATION OF THE PAROLE
OUTPATIENT CLINICS IN SUPPORT
FUNDING THE CDC ARE I THINK IT
WAS GREAT REASONS FOR THIS
PROGRAM TO BE DEVELOPED IN THE
FIFTIES TO SERVE THIS HIGH RISK
POPULATION MOST OF WHOM
pSUFFERED. SERIOUS PERSISTENT
MENTAL ILLNESS THESE
INDIVIDUALS NEED. CAREFUL ON
CLOSELY SUPERVISED TRANSITIONED
INTO THE COMMUNITY TO HELP
REDUCE THE RECIDIVISM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MAINTAIN THEIR METAL.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE MY NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND. SEVENTY NINE
NINE TWO SEVEN NINE. HI I'M TO
RESERVE THEIR A LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER I OPPOSE
THE ELIMINATION OF P. O. C. AS
WE PROVIDE NO BARRIER ACCESS TO
CARE. SERVICES ARE FREE. LONGER
CONTINUE TO THE PARK THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE ONE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN TWO
THREE SEVEN. TWO THREE SEVEN WE
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK ONE TWO
THREE SEVEN. I HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU. I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF THOSE WHO ARE CALLED IN AND
MADE THEIR ISSUES KNOWN- THEY
WERE BEING NOTED BY THOSE WHO
WORK FOR US OF THE THAT YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT CERTAIN ISSUES
AND OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE SOME
SIMILAR CONCERNS ARE WITH
REGARDS TO IT SO I WANT TO
THANK THOSE OF YOU WHO CALLED
IN WANT TO THANK THOSE WHO ARE
HERE TO TESTIFY FROM LA AS WELL
AS THOSE FROM THE- FINANCE
OFFICE AND KNOW IF THERE'S ANY
OF THE COMMENTS FOR BT MEMBERS
WHO PRESENT. OKAY I WANT TO
THANK THEM EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE THANK YOU FOR THE HEARING
AND FOR THE INFORMATION AND
THIS A- HEARING IS THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S A GERMAN.